last night
i think it was last night was the
grammys and i don't really know if it
was last night i think it was because i
don't care about the grammys i don't
watch the grammys and i don't think
anybody here did watch the grammys
anybody no
no nobody watched the grammys nobody
watched the grammys nobody cared to
watch the grammys but there was
something interesting
that's either either a sign of the
expansion
of the extremism that we see in the
mainstream
corporate media or it's a sign that
they're becoming so utterly desperate
that they're willing to cling onto
any narrative that they think will make
them money because this
rapper performed a song where he
actually depicted riots
and they did a very propagandized
version of the rayshard brooks incident
and then activist tamika mallory who's
considered to be particularly
controversial
notably when the new york times called
her out for anti-semitism
came out and gave a speech essentially
where she said we don't need allies we
need accomplices
which could be seen as like advocating
for crime and calling for people to do
more and it's kind of crazy to
mainstream program the grammys would do
something like this
i guess the ratings are in the trash so
probably
probably nobody really wants to watch
and they were hoping that
people like me would call them out to
generate some kind of buzz for their
failing program
which is a part of the conversation as
well so we have so we have a lot to talk
about
in this culture war space we also have
now uh team vogue right they tried to
hire this editor-in-chief lady
and employees at teen vogue tried to
cancel this new hire
so they ended up losing a seven-figure
ad deal backfiring canceling themselves
and we're going to talk about this
because we have one of the best people
to actually talk about music
and comedy as well as what may be viewed
as find support for
performances and things like that we are
joined today by rocker
ali speak up a little bit like i
couldn't hear you
you might want you might want to take
off the mask all right
what's up you want to pull the
microphone up to your mouth now there
you go
how's that it sounds good yeah so uh
rucka you said that you're a rapper a
musician and a self-described black
activist
yeah that sounds about right but you
mean like an activist for black lives
matter or like you know
black issues or were you just screwing
with me no i i was telling you the truth
so do you want to introduce yourself for
the show
hey everybody nice to see you good
evening my name is raka rucka ali
the last black man on the internet
and you might be asking what the f are
you doing here
i'll tell you i'm here to ask tim poole
some questions about the cat
oh snap in the hat that is
of the doctor yeah oh yeah doctors who's
a big fan
aren't we all yeah yeah yeah so you were
very concerned about the the that story
about the cat
in the hat in the hand yeah but that
book was fine so
we don't have much to worry about in
that front i think people want to hear
your opinion about it you know anything
you might have to say
all right all right i see where this is
going uh but no no for real
outside of that you you like you want to
actually get into your politics and your
philosophy because you're actually a
pretty serious guy yeah we'll get in
we can get into anything yeah because
biden wants to raise taxes
okay now we're not supposed to swear i
saw that look on your face
family show listen you know there's a
lot of anti-corporate sentiment i'm
seeing around the world right now
a lot of people saying they're
suspicious of anyone who
is making money and cares about their
money but you should see the look on
tim's face just now when i was about to
demonetize this whole thing with some
how dare you oh what's the matter need
your little money what happened to free
speech or die
yeah we're about that but i mean we're
not staunch libertarians here on the
show
oh you're only libertarian uh until it's
time to protect your uh monetization
status
absolutely yes of course and then i
think we should have a bunch of armed
guards
you know i'm kidding no i think that's
usually how it ends i think there's
actually a good philosophical
conversation about the limits of free
speech
you know i think there's a lot of good
conversations we've got ahead of us
tonight so don't go anywhere we'll be
right
back after this after after ian's
introduction
what up everybody hey thanks for coming
thanks guys good to see you buddy
um you can follow me in but let's get it
going
hey let me be honest with you i just met
you i don't
something about you bothers me you look
like one of these musicians you know
goes out you play the gig and that's
cool but then we catch you
out back of the venue after the show
you've had a few drinks
and you're a little loose with the
language you're dropping like little a
few gamer words here and there
no camera words getting a little handsy
with the ladies uh without
written consent i'm like keanu reeves
man that describes ian
one inch off the back you've read him
like a book i'm good with stereotypes
i don't know the stereotype i get for me
and is like dmt hippie
where's the dmt not here it's illegal we
don't do
we're very much in favor of law and
authority on this show have you smoked
dmt before
i don't think so i'm mostly kidding by
the way but it is illegal
this is a family-friendly show your
body's making it though it's in your
muscles and your brain
hey man it grows in the ground why can't
i smoke it with my
infant bro it's natural what do you hate
guys
you showed me a little tour of your
house i've seen some hidden rooms that i
don't even think the previous owners
knew about that's right
and the first thought i had when i saw
those rooms is like back when marijuana
was illegal this would be weird
prohibition
like chicago i'm from chicago see i know
what's up you get it you know where you
grow that
but i actually have friends chicago you
can actually find buildings that are old
speak
old like i'll put this away i i used to
hang out this house where
the bathroom window made no sense
because when you open it it was a brick
wall
but then if you reached your hand along
the wall you would find there was an
opening to your left
and they would transfer like little bits
of beer like jugs and stuff back and
forth
so it was the weirdest thing of a
building with a window to a brick wall
but it was like
kind of obvious when you thought about
it i guess during prohibition people are
a lot stupider so the cops were like
this this window seems perfectly normal
even though it looks at a brick wall
no problem here and that's how they
talked back then yeah so that's like how
the cops were
i don't i don't know why people think
that did they really talk that way back
then of course they used to talk that
way back then
what do you think you weren't there yeah
now i don't know what you're trying to
get at but i don't like it let me tell
you
sit down and hear what i have to say see
harry truman is a great example
did he talk like that harry truman yeah
i heard that it was actually the
recording technology we had back then
cut off like the mid-ranges so you hear
a higher pitched version teddy roosevelt
they didn't talk like this you know
someday they're going to see
like footage of president trump and
they're going to think this is just the
average
guy in 23rd they're right oh my gosh
all right well we also have a sour patch
electricity i am here in the corner i'm
pushing buttons we're going to laugh a
lot tonight i think we have a great
time ladies and gentlemen before we get
started head over to timcast.com and
become a member to get exclusive
members only segments and help support
the show because
i think rocco's gonna try and get us
banned i'm only half kidding
i don't have to try oh god oh oh
oh oh we got a three four person go oh
why all right
i want you all super chatting very nice
things about me or i will not hesitate
to turn this thing down don't do it we
will be remaining uh spending the
remainder of the show reading super
chats and nothing more
or we will get complete silence all
right all right all right this is why
you gotta join timcast.com because we
got
we got troublemakers on the show
sometimes you know they're just want to
turn the computer off
but uh i attempt to come don't forget to
like share subscribe hit the
notification bell
and uh let's let's check out the story
real quick so this is from buzzfeed
they say lil babies powerful grammy
performance
that referenced george floyd gave me
chills he deserves an award just for
that performance they say my god he just
did the damn thing amazing so he's like
wearing this fake bulletproof vest
and they show this mock incident of ray
sharp brooks now for those that don't or
don't remember rae shark brooks was
the guy who was driving drunk and he was
in the wendy's drive-through when he
passed out drunk
because he wouldn't move someone called
the cops made him in the restaurant
when the police showed up they were like
you know out of the vehicle you've had
too much to drink
when they tried to arrest him he
actually fought the cops punched on the
cops in the face there's multiple camera
angles of the security footage body cams
and then actually grabbed the taser and
hit one of the cops with it knock him to
the ground the cop hit his head got a
concussion
when he ran for it the cop the other cop
gave chase
rachar brooks turned and then fired the
second cartridge from the taser
and that's when the cop drew his weapon
and shot the guy twice
and it killed him we saw a lot of media
propaganda they put out this fake clip
this fake
this fake still from the incident where
they tried claiming the cop kicked the
guy when he was down kicked brooks when
he's down
it didn't happen but now what we're
seeing at the grammys of all things
is they're doing this reenactment where
in the reenactment it's like the guy
just peacefully gets on the ground and
like puts his hands up
and it is not at all what you see in the
actual body camera footage
for those that don't actually know the
story they would see this
and they would believe the activist
narrative as opposed to the actual truth
this is one of the biggest problems we
have right now i think in the country
is that a lot of people they get their
information second hand
they get it distilled by people with
political motives and agendas and that's
true of this show
and it's true of the grammys granted i
think we're a bit more discerning and a
bit
more honest on this show and there are
many other political commentators who
will be more honest but for the most
part
when it filters through people with
agendas you get lies and
misrepresentations
but the bigger thing about this was that
they brought out team tamika mallory
the reason that's interesting is because
she's been accused of pushing
anti-semitic conspiracy theories this
was by the new york times
and it made everybody really question
the women's march of which she was one
of the principal organizers
and i think there was a big controversy
like some groups broke up some pulled
out
a bunch of actors like we don't want to
be involved in this because she's got
questionable uh associations in this
a speech or whatever she said we don't
need allies we need accomplices
and the crazy thing is when they're
doing this depiction of riots is kind of
a good thing
and they're having this activist come
out and say these things i think it's
actually
fairly worrying so i guess the bigger
question though is
the political ramifications of this and
whether or not we should actually even
care about the grammys
both because it's a trap it's trash and
their writings are trash and no one
cares about the grammys or more
importantly because
should we get all hot and bothered by
offensive performances
you know because we don't like it so
rucka considering you're you
you do these videos you clearly have no
issue um what's the right word being a
troublemaker i guess
i'm curious actually what you think
about you know this kind of stuff i
don't know if you've been following this
but
i know you're you're you're you're a bit
philosophical right yeah
so what what are you what's your
thoughts on what's been gone in this
past year and like
the grammys for instance i mean it used
to be like
you know 95 music and five percent you
know
let's take this opportunity to remember
that like killing unarmed civilians
uh you know and calling them gamer word
with your arm
with your boot on their neck in their
dying moments is not the way to uh
progress forward as a nation now it's
like a hundred and ten percent
statements and like one percent
music music and i you know people are
gonna say oh that's way more percentage
points
than logic permits so i'm gonna pass it
along to the
the smart looking guy here to explain
that i think accomplice is a legal term
for meaning that you're there for the
crime so i mean that's like a legal term
it's a weird word to use at the grammys
when you're talking about
street violence definitely yeah when
you're talking about people burning down
a wendy's that had nothing to do with
anything
i guess they were mad the wendy's
employees called the police because
there was a drunk driver blocking their
driveway
and so they called so then decided to
burn the wendy's down
does that make sense no it doesn't make
sense but
like i think they're um they're they've
got premises
that most people unfortunately have so
like do you ever hear people saying like
um we gotta stop big tech you know we
gotta stop letting big tech
treat us this way so they're taking all
these separate companies grouping them
as though they're a monolith and wanting
to basically either punish them or
hamper them collectively
so why shouldn't uh all stores around
the neighborhood get punished
collectively
if people are upset at the police this
is not a stretch this is not a reach i'm
i think i'm
making a point you're not going to hear
anywhere but the tim cass podcast please
go to timkas.org
um there's a big difference between a
fast food restaurant that called the
cops
and big tech companies that actually
have meetings together and are proven to
actually collude with each other to
remove political dissent
so like there's not a concerted effort
among wendy's mcdonald's and burger king
to to frame black individuals who fall
asleep in their driveways
it was just some employee who was like
yo there's some guy like sleeping in the
driveway can you help us
and then when he fought the cops he
ended up losing his life which is bad by
the way i mean cops should not
be judge jury executioner but this is a
guy who grabbed a taser and turned and
was trying to fire it
at the cop you can argue if the cops
should not have used lethal force or
whatever that's
that's something but look you you know
as well as i do people talk about
silicon valley as if it's a monolith so
yeah maybe twitter
facebook facebook twitter and youtube
may be met together but at the same time
there's like
a trillion other companies that are
hoping to someday be at that level
they're doing plenty of work and these
companies are also trying to compete
against one another
but they're they're lumped together
mentally as though they're a monolith
and i'm just i'm just pointing that out
that's horrible that's a good point
thank you we can move on corporate media
that gets thrown around i don't trust
the corporate media tim cass
tim cass is a corporation it's a media
corporation i trust it
i work for it but like yeah i i guess i
agree you know we can absolutely do that
i think in terms of
big tax silicon valley there's kind of
like a theme people tend to be getting
at
they control technology and
infrastructure and then with like
wendy's getting burnt to the ground
i don't know would you support you know
google being burnt to the ground because
activists were mad that there was hate
speech on it
of course not i don't i don't support
even demonizing google or
or uh condemning these companies in the
vast majority of cases or in some cases
yeah criticize them harshly but uh
obviously i don't
i don't allow any level of violence by
private citizens
um we got a rule of law hmm rule of law
i mean and you see i know i hate to
bring this up five minutes into the show
but when you look at the capital
storming
you're seeing a bunch of reckless people
treating
everyone in that building as though
they're part of this uh concerted effort
to uh
deprive them of their of their rights or
something like that i mean
we need to think critically we need to
be clear so yeah
well so what are your thoughts on uh
just like i guess the wokification and
the activist
activistification of media and like you
know the grammys awards shows
commercials commercial products
i'll i'll put it this way you know
you're you're talking
it sounds like you're in defense of
these these corporations to a certain
degree is that fair to say
depends what they're being accused of
sure sure
uh i'm i'm saying like you know i see
two big power monopolies government and
corporations
and i think left unchecked power tends
to corrupt absolutely
so i don't care if you're the government
i don't care if you're
big oil or big tech or big wendy's
you know or other grammy's pushing out a
political message i think it's a problem
when
too much power is concentrated in a
specific area
you don't think you're what someone
could call big youtuber
i'm big i'm a youtuber you're a big
youtuber
you have a lot more influence than a lot
of people so like
you you could always look at somebody
much bigger and say oh they no one
should have that much power but we know
it's not
power power is force power is pointing a
gun at somebody okay now we're getting
demonetized
i meant meta well no actually i mean
that's fine yeah i mean i talked about
the killing of a dude by cops
i think we need to differentiate
economic power from political power
and the more we conflate the two the
more we conflate political and economic
power the more we're going to see
economic power become
the government like that is corporations
have friends in washington
and and we're going to see political
power basically politicians taking over
the economy taking over industry so it's
an ugly thing to watch it but
it's been happening over 100 years over
longer than 100 years so i keep in mind
a lot of the
outrageousness we see today is like the
culmination
of decades and decades and decades of
of these changes taking place so there
was always radicals
talking about killing cops for many
decades um we've had all types of
shenanigans people burning down the city
when they're
unsatisfied this goes back probably to
the days of like
irish people in the 19th century or
whatnot i don't mean to insult any irish
people i love gingers i love everybody
who
looks like that um i'm just saying this
was like the um what do you guys know
what that thing was in chicago
where the anarchists like there was an
explosion what was that what was that i
don't know that much about it i used to
know a lot more about this i forgot it's
been
it's been a minute but i think that's a
fair point uh to mention too is that
like
the extremism used to be substantially
worse i think in not just this country
but many other countries
where you actually had like you know the
weather underground was planting bombs
and actually detonating them
now we have widespread riding over the
past year which
arguably could be worse and that's
causing way more damage disrupting way
more people's lives
but i think you know you go back a
hundred years this is really bad
i mean you you've had treason you've had
sedition you've had
literal plots that involve high-powered
weapons and warships
and we're actually it's kind of like
fading a bit you know in the conflicts
we're getting into now are
mostly people protesting and pushing
each other and shoving some people get
arrested and they scream police
brutality
and then they they do burn down
buildings and stuff so my fear is
whether or not this escalates into more
serious violence
that's what i don't want to happen
there's no question that crime has gone
down overall
over the last few decades i i don't
think there's any question of that so
like overall
we've gotten more civilized but like
what we've seen not just this
not just in 2020 but i mean you know
there's been plenty of rioting and
looting and all types of
outrageous stuff happening you know for
for some time but like 2020 was the year
of get no more f's to give right yeah
and um i don't feel like this country is
my home anymore
you know that's kind of the feeling i
got in the summer of 2020 that's how i
felt on january 6th
and i know someone's gonna comment oh
that's 2021.
how about i come over there and we
settle this get all of your little
uh dvd collecting proud boys
and i'll get all my blm people and we'll
settle this
commenters i'm gonna find every last one
of you what do you mean summer of 2020
you're talking about the the
the rioting the the elements burning
down wendy's and
private private businesses and um
uh police stations i mean it's out
absolutely uh disheartening to say the
least and um
and i was wondering is it gonna seep
into residential areas like what what it
does
okay but i mean is it going to basically
just be home after home getting
broken into and that's it goodbye to any
semblance of civilization i just had a
horrific
portent about the chinese military
invading and swiftly taking over the
united states like a blitzkrieg
like if we were stupid enough to to let
her go like they were running war games
and they're like no
we can't stop the chinese if they
attacked us no we talked uh about this
with james lindsay are you familiar with
with james
maybe he he's he's like a very uh he's a
he's a the preeminent scholar on
critical race theory in in terms of
criticizing it and what's what it's
doing and this like wokeness and things
like that
and what he was mentioning when it comes
to china is that they're using political
warfare
so it seems more like they're
interfering in our culture they're
interfering in our advertisements our
our
you know cultural creations our tv shows
our radio programs our schools and
things like that
so you end up with ultra woke grammys
asking for people to basically commit
crimes
this is the thing this performance they
did and the reason i think it's
important to bring up is that
it's not that they're directly saying
hey go commit crimes they're showing
riots
viewing those riots as the good guys
like they're depicting that is they're
the good guys the cops the bad guys the
people burning down the buildings or the
black lives matter activists who are
fighting
the who are the good guys then they say
we need accomplices
they're advocating for tearing ourselves
apart
this is people in the united states
pointing the finger at the united states
and saying
burn it down burn it all down that's a
direct quote from a lot of these
activists they've jumped up on cars and
they've yelled burn it all down
do you think people in china do that
they don't now first and foremost
they're not legally allowed to and
that's that's kind of scary
that you've got these two views in the
u.s you're allowed to so we actually
just fight ourselves and scream at each
other
and then in china they're forced to you
know this authoritarian system keeps
them in line
and they're growing rapidly they're
expanding they're engaging in political
warfare with us and then we're on the
verge of falling apart
i mean that was a bold statement you
just made which statement you didn't
feel like this was your country i mean
it was a true statement it was an
emotional
uh tell i mean yeah like seeing
uh you know melrose avenue beverly hills
seeing you know
seeing beautiful things destroyed and
not only
destroyed but being like apologized for
that
meaning like people downplaying the
severity of it and people
encouraging it um i just i don't feel
like la
is a city where i could meet somebody in
the street and and feel a bond with them
now obviously a lot of people were not
happy with what took place to put it
lightly but
but i mean the fact that culturally
people are comfortable
encouraging such behavior says that
morally
you know in in the way people think
about ethics these
people have the people committing that
type of violence have the moral high
ground that's why they're comfortable
getting on the grammys
and and saying we need accomplices so i
mean the question to ask is not i think
not so much what's wrong with critical
race theory but what's the alternative
what are you offering
as an alternative uh classical
liberalism interesting
interesting uh statement yeah now what
does that mean to you
classical liberalism is typically about
protecting the rights of the individual
and i mean that's the strongest uh way
to put it so
i don't know is there any more specific
well i mean uh i think
versus like what we're seeing with
critical race theory is race-based
collectivism
so we can get into yeah i mean i i i
like where you're going with this but is
there a period of time
in american history for instance you
would say that's like when the classical
liberals hung out
what do you mean like would you say the
founding fathers would you say the 1940s
like is there a period of time no uh
there's some there's some elements of
classical liberal
liberalism that have existed in the
united states at various at various
periods but it's never been like
has it ever been more than less is there
is there like i don't think the us has
ever been
mostly classically liberal or
libertarian
in that regard interesting if you go
back to the founding fathers for
instance
slavery like there's no question people
were kept as property
and more importantly while the the ideas
of classical liberalism helped drive
the idea that we no longer had to be
under the knee
of some you know divine prominence the
king declaring it
we certainly didn't have absolute
freedoms there was cultural uh
enforcement of various ideas women not
being able to do certain things
certain things but we've progressed
greatly my issue now is that we got to
this period where it was like it was
almost going to get pretty good you know
in the 90s we saw censorship
but we had that air we had people like
george carlin and we had you know
he was he was willing to be offensive
and say things that really ruffled
feathers
we do have people like that today still
now we're starting to get hard pushback
for more moral authoritarians again
and so my my my thing is like we don't
want critical race theory we don't want
race-based collectivism that to me is
nightmarish
right there's this guy who just went
viral early today because he he tweeted
to bill burr
who's got a black wife that it may be a
sign of racism
and he referred to bill burr's wife and
he's claiming he didn't but he did
as a minority
adult use slave we'll put it there like
sally hemmings
he he he literally claimed like bill
burr was keeping this woman around for
his pleasure as a slave and it was one
of the most shockingly disgusting things
i've heard from a critical race theorist
so i'm like hey let's respect the
individual let's live and let live let's
let's have some some we we need some
regulation and some restriction but we
mostly want individual freedom
we there's there's an interesting debate
in the idea of collectivism in that
there does have to be some
not none but that we're going in the
wrong direction with it
does that answer your question am i did
i do a good job i mean you gave me your
point of view
um i so i think the topic of slavery and
women's suffrage
complicates things in a way that's
difficult for me to make the point that
i'm trying to make but
obviously in most of history slavery and
ownership of women basically
pushing you know telling women what to
do has been the norm i think your
co-host looks like he still supports
those things
why are you wrecking on the end so much
man you gotta have that guy
it's like a grounding rod yeah um ian's
the opposite of those things he's like
the leftiest guy on the show he's so
nice okay
i'm saying now
but like in so i think in their time uh
the enlightenment thinkers you know the
age of reason as thomas paine
i think dubbed it uh people like
benjamin franklin thomas jefferson
george washington and you know people
joke people laugh at you now especially
people on the right they mock you for
saying this but
in their context in their time in
history even though slavery was a norm
even though women
were still largely seen as basically
trading cards
in their context they were taking a very
bold new step
yeah for man in drafting the declaration
of independence
saying life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and they were going to have
property
did you know this they were going to
have property life liberty property and
the pursuit of happiness and i wish they
had
it in there in order to help us have a
lot more capitalism for a lot longer
possibly but you know why they didn't
have property in there
because they didn't they wanted to stick
it to the slaveholders because they knew
they would use their
so-called property their slaves as an
extra vote or something like that
all right but so when you look at
context when you see uh that when you
look at the history of philosophy and
all of the
uh great brave steps that it took to go
from
the um the just blurry and reckless
ancient and prehistoric even before that
prehistoric
times to get to a point where you have
intellectuals
establishing a country being willing to
fight for it but then once the war is
won
to sit and debate painstakingly and to
um
to look at ask what is human nature what
is the best
type of society for a human being to
live and to pursue life liberty
and his own happiness to get to that
point is a magnificent intellectual
achievement that we take for granted so
when i say classical liberal i'm talking
about those guys i'm talking about the
age of reason
and i'm not talking about what came
after them especially in america
like intellectuals that pragmatists
utilitarians
uh progressives obviously and of course
we get the postmoderns and we get the uh
you know the critical race theorists
which is probably
an offshoot of post-modern or something
i'm not i'm not an expert like your
previous guest
go i agree with you on the founding
fathers they it a lot of people don't
realize this but it wasn't just a
political revolution it was an
ideological revolution
a lot of people a lot of countries in
the world were under the crown or
some monarch or some autocrat or some
kind of system where it was
you know these kings would say by divine
providence i
am the king god wills it you know and
then they would just tell people do it
or else and they had people who are
loyal to that idea and to them
and then all of a sudden you get these
this this group of people in in the u.s
some of some of them i i've read a
little bit about this
the authority of the founding fathers
was questioned even by some like based
on how they were voted to represent the
colony they came from because it was
like
who saith this colony that you represent
them and want independence but is there
a lot of people who are like
yo we don't need a king we can rule by
the
consent of the government we can create
something new it's truly profound
and there were a lot of ideas but i
think when you look back at history
while i absolutely take the good from
the founding fathers
i've got the coin collection for thomas
jefferson i love it i think the dude was
a genius
i also think he was a product of his
times there's a lot of things back then
we criticize
the reason i don't highlight all of
those and emphasize them and condemn the
founding fathers over those things is
that we've changed
and we don't want to be like we hate
these people because they did bad things
somebody say
we want to say they did bad things but
here these really really good things
we're keeping now
but i don't think it's fair to point out
i mean they did a lot of bad things but
that we're not here to talk about them
as people we're talking about the ideas
that they promoted and the effect that
what made them stand out in history and
so while i agree with you
about the founding fathers for their
time was a radical bunch of classical
liberal types fighting for
the rights of the individual against
this king willing to literally fight and
die
and many of the signatories of the
declaration of independence had their
legacies their names and their lives
stripped away from them
there was that was a bold and amazing
bunch of people
to go back then i think would be a rude
awakening for for a lot of people today
in terms of what you could or couldn't
do
because of cultural and social
enforcement so that's that's my big
concern today with things like critical
race theory black lives matter and
commercials
that it's not so much about what's legal
you're allowed to go and do things it's
about
someone will dig up a tweet from you
from 10 years ago and then you can never
get a job again you're basically being
ostracized
for something at the time was fine and
now isn't well that's cultural
enforcement imagine having such
magnificent technology where you can do
such a thing as tweet and then someone
else can dig up that tweet and you don't
need and nobody's forcing you to sign up
for twitter in the first place and
there's the the technology we're living
with is what they would have
called science fiction a very short time
ago let alone going back in the day so
and i'm not saying let's go back and
live like
washington and jefferson i'm saying we
need to uh
look at the ideas that they came up with
fine-tune them
and expand them to everybody you know
include all races and
all all all 78 genders i'm saying
there's 144
that i think no i mean they have and
anyone who identifies at any gender
obviously has the right to do that i
think we all can agree with that um
but um they don't have the right to
require somebody else to call to call
them anything or to treat them any
certain which is which is part of what
i'm saying about cultural enforcement so
look obviously but also like you can't
really speak about what's taking place
in the culture
and not acknowledge the fact that we
have a largely
meddled with economy so we have business
and government largely blended together
regulation and subsidies right so favors
and penalties
you got to divorce the two and that's
exactly uh what the founding fathers
should have done more explicitly they
did a pretty good job
implementing a separation of state from
economics not a perfect job but a pretty
good job
but they should have put it in writing
so in the co in the constitution it
should have said
separate church from state separate
economics from state wouldn't that be
one i don't think separation of church
of state is in the constitution though
wherever it is i think it was just like
an ideal of the founding fathers that
was enshrined in like their writings and
i don't know if it is maybe the
federalist papers or something i think
it is isn't it
well i guess the first amendment is what
you would say is kind of where we get
that right
right the right of the individual to be
we're this is the place for the highest
cutting-edge intellectuals on the
internet right now we got tim pool we
got me
we got this mother hey hey and it's
dragging on ian and producer
lydia lydia yes yeah
so here's what i mean by uh i want to go
back to cultural enforcement
if we want to take these good ideas from
the founding fathers i completely agree
with you
i want those to be put more in
application today have the individual
the right
anybody who wants to identify as
whatever they want can you can be
respected and live their lives
but it's the authoritarianism it's the
if you don't say this
you're fired right we had an actor on
the show uh last week and he was saying
like
he goes to these rehearsals and they're
all announcing their pronouns
and it's not it's not like as a law but
you know what happens if you refuse to
do it
you don't get your job and you don't
work and then you may as well
find a different career one that's not
been infected by this cultural dogma
so if you want classical liberalism
you've got to contend with the fact that
you know politics is downstream from
culture we can get a bunch of great
politicians to talk about a bunch of
great ideas
but then if no one is willing to do
certain things because they're scared
their neighbors will yell at them it
just won't happen
yeah i mean look you know i said you
can't you can't look at the way
the world is going and people are having
their livelihoods destroyed and all
types of problems without
acknowledging the fact we have a
regulatory state and a largely
tampered with economy but i'll go
further and say you can't look at the
way people behave and what they believe
without acknowledging the history of
philosophy so
the fact we have a world where so many
people uh
think they can invent their own gender
or that we live in a world where
people think that you know calling for
accomplices in basically overthrowing
civil order is acceptable and that is
conducive to
life on earth it speaks to philosophical
development so
i will offer you the following after the
founding fathers and the men of the age
of reason
and maybe some women as well i don't
know um
sort of came up with their innovations
in philosophy and they discovered that
the nature of man calls for his rights
to be protected
by a government with a monopoly on force
and i think john locke
john d have you even read locke you know
played a large role in
in providing people like thomas payne
with
uh those ideas but after america was
established
the um the intellectuals of the
generations after them
uh they put all of their effort into
basically reversing
what the founders had implemented
intellectually so
the uh what they call the um
before the progressives uh the the uh
pragmatists
pragmatism is the american philosophy
not the founders philosophy but like the
post-founding american philosophy you go
to any public school you go to any
house of learning since you know
sometime in the 19th century and onward
pragmatism was like the uh was the
american
philosophy which it was influenced by
the germans it was influenced by hegel
um and other and kant and other
philosophers who rejected
certainty they said look all you know is
you can't be certain i mean they said a
lot of other things too but
once that was in place one's
intellectual said that the individual
cannot
look at the world independently observe
it independently
and be rational about it and make
indepen independently rational
decisions and live and should be
protected
in doing so that his rights right to do
so should be protected
once they were rejecting that type of
independence
and the rejected reason in essence the
era
of the founders was over the era of the
age of reason
was over and now you had educators
basically training students
to be well socialized young boys and
girls they were teaching
them to be sheep they were teaching them
not to think and
with each generation we've seen it get
worse we've seen people get
less independent less rational we've
seen random acts of violence you know
in the 19th century there would be
someone who would shoot up people
randomly and it was shocking but it
happened
obviously jumped forward to modern times
and before this lockdown it was like
every two weeks
uh some potentially worse now yeah but i
mean when you reject reason
at the highest levels of the
intellectual world then what do you
expect kids to be taught in
you know elementary school think about
that the idea of
you know divine providence or whatever
that just
trust me the lord wills that i be king
or whatever you got to take away reason
from an individual
if you want to establish a system like
that for the longest time
people didn't reason it just was and so
long as you had the zealotry
the king could maintain power yeah i'm
going to make i'm going to make a
statement that's going to get me in
trouble but i'm going to say it anywhere
we go donald trump's presidency
is in is in a certain way similar to
like the way you're describing the
american revolution and the founding
fathers
you're you're angry now see hold on let
me let me tell you why all right i'm not
i'm not saying because i i think
but i'll get the idea i'm not saying
because trump was right i'm not saying
because trump was good
i'm saying because it was basically an
affront to the established order
that donald trump was not supposed to
win whatever it is he was doing was
was offensive to those in power and so
they very much did not like him and said
this can't happen again
i look back at the founding fathers and
you have this point where there was a
deviation
away from the crown and the absolute
authority
of those who were you know willed to be
kings and like you mentioned
all of a sudden generation after
generation they've stripped away reason
and taught children to be better and
better sheep till
now here we are well i mean uh i i think
a lot of people who like trump
um that are whom are not bad people
would probably say they were drawn to
him for reasons that you described
because they see a sort of push back
against authority authority or being
told
what to do and they see him as sort of
this uh kind of independent guy that
doesn't let the media or anyone tell him
what to do
i get that but left um sort of
unchecked like kind of left without um
without any correction what trump i
think represents is just this
dispensing with any sort of rational
method trump says what passes through
his head
and that becomes so-called reality and
his fans
love it they're willing to die on that
hill um quite literally i think
so a decent amount of them i would say
you know look out of 74.2 million people
it was a much smaller fight i'm not
talking about about anyone who voted for
him because a lot of people voted for
trump as the lesser of two evils or even
because they liked some things about him
but i mean i'm talking about
what trump represents the way he's
influenced the republican party the way
he's influenced the way people go about
politics
um i think he definitely represents a
serious development for the worst but i
i get where you're coming from when you
say that kind of emotionally he
he speaks to people sen sort of like the
ghost of the founding fathers
in i don't even mean that though no i'm
just saying like you have an established
order you have the other
democratic and republican establishment
and then all of a sudden trump comes
along and he's a bull
just stamping stampeding through and
kind of just knocking over their stuff
i'm not saying there's an equivalence in
his philosophy
i'm saying that you have you have kings
you have colonization you have war
you have monarchs autocrats and here
come the founding fathers saying
screw you what you gonna do about it
physically fought remember the founding
fathers were intellectuals and when they
weren't
killing the british they were taking a a
lot of time to make sure they got it
right and they had beliefs about the
nature of man and they were
intellectuals and it was really the one
time in history that intellectuals were
also blowing heads off but then
carefully crafting out a system of
government so i could basically flip
that and say the way trump behaves the
way he's willing to basically smash the
system reminds me of some
attilas in history some genghis khan
sure so
i mean by the way by the way kings kings
are not a natural fact of history like
uh kings and king
the rule of kings did not just evolve
like uh like the chimpanzee
the the king there was a time when there
was like let's say democracy in greece
far from perfect but much better than
you know just the king and the pope
right telling peasants how to live uh
there was wrong
there was rome which was you know also a
senate type of system there was there
were um
ancient sort of ages of reason where
they where they highly embraced reason
and they really wanted to get it right
and
so how did we go from that to the dark
age which very much exists
it seems like i think we're getting into
that it's possible i think it was the
rejection of reason which is why you get
brutes in charge but real quick sorry do
you think we're heading into another
dark age
if we uh on the route we're going
absolutely i i'm sad to say
i mean listen i can't predict something
like that like let's say it's possible
that authoritarianism is on the rise
but let's say technology is just
developing so fast and people love it so
much that the authoritarians don't want
to take that away from people
like there's a there's a number of um
outcomes
that where this can take us that i
cannot predict i can't just
rationalistically say
up like all the all the things add up
like it all adds up we're going to have
um authoritarianism i can't predict that
but
the way we're going the way that reason
is being rejected the way that brute
force is being celebrated and we're
seeing brute force
a lot and so to have um somebody like
trump
in such a prominent place in society i
think
sadly does not say something positive
about where we're heading i like how
many nods i've been getting from you you
know i uh
i'm happy i feel i feel comfortable i'm
i'm happy to be here
get your ideas and your thoughts you
know what i mean i'll give you mine but
i will clarify too i'm not saying trump
is like the founding fathers
we can argue that there was an
aberration in the established order
where the founding fathers pushed us
heavy towards individualism and freedom
and then with trump it was a rejection
of establishment they're not the same
thing
right so the point i was making more so
was that
the powers that be were outraged and
what i see is
with trump there was this this concerted
effort to fortify the election as time
magazine called it
because they did not want trump to to
you know
become president again or to get
re-elected with the founding fathers
i absolutely believe you know what you
were saying is true there's there's a
lot of people
probably just because the system is
exploitable when you when you have
freedom it's very difficult to maintain
because
cheaters can cheat it's not true you
don't think so then how have they done
it
have they done what over time our system
has been exploited to push for the
lowest common denominator
our school systems are are making you
know our youth
institutionalized and incapable and now
we end up with a generation
of millennials saddled with massive debt
for degrees they can't use
and what skills have they earned from
spending all this money and just
being extracted essentially by sal you
know what it's said freddie mac and
sally mayor the name of the company
or these these these big loans or sally
i don't know the companies are i think
this is your place for mortgage uh info
yeah that's right
you got all the news no i just mean like
listen i mean to go from the founding
fathers
freedom to now have people demanding
communism
well not only are they demanding calm i
don't even know how much
people are demanding communism i think
people like let's say on the far left
are demanding some type something even
uglier than communism like some kind of
cambodian egalitarianism where everyone
with any level of privilege is shaved
down
that's a scary thing listen i can i can
sit here and throw red meat all day to
people on the ride and say these
leftists are as bad as you think but
but we're not only seeing calls for that
we're seeing calls for authoritarianism
we want people want donald trump to rule
and they want the next guy josh hawley
or somebody worse than him to be
like a populist loudmouth piece of trash
who does not care about principles so
how did we go from the founding fathers
to this basically it was the dispensing
of reason so the founding fathers did
not emerge in a vacuum they were
they were part of a tradition of the
development of the of philosophy
after them like i said the um the
utilitarians the um
the pragmatists came along what did the
pragmatists say they said you can't
really
live by principles right principles are
too um they're too constricting and you
know you don't really know if they're
gonna work so what do you do
just act just act and see if it worked
and so how do you know how to act right
just well you can't use uh principles
right so just
whatever you feel do what you feel bro
that is unfortunately become the
american way so
in essence i see donald trump as like
the pragmatist president
he's not the worst president he
represents the worst of the intellectual
or the or the first worst of the
intellectual there's there's been worse
intellectuals than the pragmatists but
but he he to me donald trump represents
the um
the absolute rejection of the founding
fathers which is why a lot of
a lot of very crappy um see i'm trying
to keep you monetized a lot of very bad
people that have emerged in last few
years a lot of very
um anti-individualistic people on the
right they love trump for a reason they
love him because he
he represents america minus any
principles minus the founding documents
minus any philosophy you have you got to
break that down a little bit
sure explain that because yes as a
statement i don't understand
so why why do you think the let's say
the alt-right loves donald trump or they
did when he ran
i i don't think they do well they did it
they wanted him to win
for nationalistic reasons okay why do
you think they love nationalism or what
do you think
they think trump represents their type
of nationalism
trump was talking about ending free
trade agreements and securing our
borders
for them it was probably an issue of
immigration and white and
and like their race and their ideals it
is very much that but also
and in addition to that on a deeper
level it's the rejection of principles
you never see trump get up there and
talk about how the founders gave us
these principles that will protect us
from government authoritarianism when
when trump uh got was inaugurated he
didn't get up there and talk about
the reverence that you know we should
have for the founders he got up there
and goes
today marks a power transfer from
the government back to the people i mean
this is this has
nothing to do with the founding
principles of america this has
nothing to do with anything i don't
think the trump supporters are rejecting
those principles i think
i'm not saying all of them again i'm not
saying all right i think you'd find they
would all agree with you
on everything you're saying about the
founding fathers well then we need to be
very meticulous in identifying what it
is we like about the founding fathers i
would say it's that they were men of
principles
and the principles of individual rights
and you know
having getting to a point where we have
a a a guy who just
invents facts out of thin air that just
occurred to him and that people are
willing to die for those so-called
utterances and that trump could later
change his mind and
they'll then change their mind as well
to have that
um i think it represents something that
absolutely rejects
any philosophy i think the amount of
people you're describing are is smaller
than you realize
i mean people who take it that far but
listen listen the people who stormed the
capital
disregarded the president himself i
don't think they care all that much
about him
those people the people who support the
president and many of them probably
blindly
were at trump's rally watching him speak
but the storming of the capital started
while trump was still speaking when
trump said
peacefully march and even people like
alex jones according to pbs
jones was saying don't fight the cops
please be peaceful
that'll be the narrative so who are
these guys who are like
we don't care what trump says certainly
they were they were trump supporters
not for they were not trump supporters
first they were something else
and they're probably these people
probably the authoritarians who think in
their minds they're the heroes of the
constitution or whatever
but if your idea of fighting for freedom
and principles and what the founding
fathers did is to just barge your way
into a constitution you know
constitutional process
that you disagree with that's literally
not more importantly
if you were going to support the
president and his fight and he said to
do it peacefully you clearly don't
support the president
so those people i don't think what trump
represents from the day that he entered
politics
is a dispensing with principles he has
always spoken about america like a
business he's going to run like an
executive he's always spoken about
economic liberty well never he never
uses that phrase but economics as though
it's for him to manage and micromanage
or to to issue declarations so
uh what trump represents is a turn away
from principles again that doesn't mean
all his voters
want to dispense with principles but
certainly people that want to dispense
with principles
people that want america minus its
founding documents people that want
america
to be a land of geography and
of of genetics people who believe that
america is just a group of people with
no relation to philosophy
people those people they see trump
rightfully as they step in
their direction now now i've gone from
the nodding with you to the shake in my
head yeah i see that because the
the alt-right is not a part a prominent
faction that's not it's not a
do we even talk about them like there's
some little group anymore
basically the republican party is
basically like they all laugh
at they all laugh at the founding
fathers at this point you go to a
republican group
they'll laugh at you come on come on you
gotta draw a line when you when you say
the genetics they want
there's a big difference between the
republican party and the alt-right
so so you can point out and criticize
the alt-right rightly so
but to act like that's trump's base
that's just absolutely not look i'm not
even concerned with trump at this point
i'm saying the republican party today
has nothing to do with
love of capitalism with the the rights
of the individual gone are the days
absolutely i completely agree gone are
they so so i'm saying look what happened
gone are the days of republicans talking
about how my you know
an immigrant could could swim here all
across the ocean
or with you know ted cruz my gran my
father had 20 dollars in his underwear
you became a dishwasher there's a guy i
absolutely hate if you get ted cruz in
here please bring me on here to
challenge him to consensual physical
combat i'm not no no no
no all right but um basketball match we
got a basketball court you got
he used to play in high school i guess
yeah well i'll play better
trust me i'm i'm from the streets look i
think i
i detest the republican party i mean
every opportunity they've had to
actually fight for what they're what
what the people are asking for they
don't do it
well the people which people like their
voters
okay what do the people want so uh i
guess it depends on what you paul but
the number one issue for
republicans is control of immigration
why is that the number one issue
for republicans so a lot of the
republicans live in rural areas
many of them saw their small towns
destroyed by a loss of industry as free
trade agreements shipped off these
factories to mexico to china
that's one of the things that bernie and
trump both had in 2015 and 16.
bernie ended up eventually just joining
the democratic establishment but trump
he's the guy where michael moore michael
moore gave the speech where he was like
donald trump went to the auto executives
and said
i will put a 30 tariff on your car
and no one will ever buy your vehicle
again
and no one had ever challenged the
executives this way for these people who
are in rural areas
one big thing they're seeing with
immigration is the job market is
depressed so their view i'm not trying
to make
certain facts i'm trying to say this is
this is the general understanding i have
when you have mass migration and
an industry being shipped overseas so
joe biden wants you know more free trade
agreements
he wants higher corporate tax and he
wants
no deportations for 100 days which he
lost that fight what ends up happening
is you have
more workers less jobs and an incentive
with higher
corporate taxes for companies to leave
and the opportunity to do so
you're going to get a donald trump who
says i'm going to reject those things
when you have rural voters who lost
their manufacturing plants who lost
their coal mining facilities of which
there weren't
that many but these manufacturing plants
were shipped overseas now they're now
they're hungry now they're desperate
donald trump says i'll get you those
things back so how did we go from being
a country where the individual's rights
are inalienable to becoming a country
where people in rural areas
have a right to their having their job
uh
you know provided to them for it not
being shipped off overseas or anything
else that
what what happened to the days of of
individuals in america
packing up back in the day when the
plant would close down they would they
would load up their
their cart and they would which move to
somewhere where there are jobs was it
the 14th
amendment the income tax one federal
reserve which one was that one
i don't know but that that that's
probably the time when when people were
were mandated to give a portion of their
income for for a guaranteed
so we agree that that was part one of
the major steps
towards the beginning of the end i say
this too i say so we need to get back
we need to get back to free market
economics and we need to get back to a
philosophical view of man that says
man's rights are inalienable including
the man who create who builds his own
company and ends up hiring
many people and then later decides that
the way the world is changing and the
way his business is growing it makes
more sense for him to move it to a
different
location in or outside the country and
the government has no place
incentivizing nor punishing that action
i agree with much of what you just said
i don't want to get into every single
point but specifically the one of the
problems with making your own company is
regulations how do you compete with a
factory in china that is none
and if you're trying so you know they
shut down your factory now you got a
bunch of workers who want to work
and you say i'd love to hire you but i
can't afford to pay 10 bucks an hour to
everybody because i got to compete with
china that pays a dollar
so now people here can't even compete
with the industry
of these other companies the higher
corporate tax you're right
the government is disincentivizing and
restricting the ability for people to
actually start their own industries
now you can go out onto your small plot
of land so you have one
and chop your own wood and hunt for your
own food if you're able to but now we've
got a whole bunch of government
regulatory problems
if you're not legally allowed to hunt
then how do you do it now you can't eat
you can't work because you don't have
the right permits and you can't compete
with china and
chinese manufacturing plants or mexican
and you can't afford to pay the minimum
wage congratulations
now it's just impossible for the
american worker they'll vote for donald
trump
look i mean america today produces more
stuff than ever before
there's there's more manufacturing in
america today than ever before
i mean i is it true it absolutely is
true and it's sad to me that in
a time when um what is google going to
give you a quick answer to that
i mean it's sad that at a time when uh
when we're
we're we're basically putting the
internet in in
in in objects that fit in your pocket
that people are not moving to places
where they can learn new skills
and look for new jobs everyone is just
going to sit there
and either accept welfare or or
uh demand that the president provide
them with the job whatever happened to
the land of the individual whatever
happened to capitalism whatever happened
to actually
do is capitalism until the chinese start
having some elements of capitalism then
we're not for it anymore it's just
it's just very sad but i think again it
i i can't argue economics this
i can argue more about philosophy the
way americans see
the rights of the individual the way
they see human nature has changed
so we agree yeah so that's that's the
battle
you are right uh nist says 1.6
manufacturing growth year over year with
uh from 2009 to 2019 about three percent
growth
over uh i think three percent over
overall annual growth rates around three
percent between 09 and 2019
and uh i don't know why they're giving
me two numbers but it's been growing it
has been growing
but but i think the issue is certain
people lose their
jobs and so they vote for trump it
brings me no joy when anyone loses their
job but believe me in a capitalist
a real capitalist society i mean i know
you have some free market
sentiments you probably agree that in an
actual capitalist society
there'd be more jobs than people able to
fill them right yeah
i think it it it's a really interesting
uh point you bring up about everything
that's going on
in that maybe people need to stop asking
the government for help even republicans
and conservatives who tend to be the
ones who argue
that they're not the ones doing that you
know what i mean
voting for trump to end these these free
trade agreements
is asking the government to bring your
companies back and donald trump did that
by using the power of government
whereas technology has dramatically
changed and the ability
to transport products overseas has made
it very very easy for companies to exist
in areas where it's easier to operate
it looks like the lack of restrictions
on chinese labor has made them
able to compete better i'm not a staunch
capitalist and by the way american
standard of living has risen because of
uh
trade with chinese companies you know
you got you got
people in rural areas going to a big
beautiful shiny walmart and buying a
wardrobe for their kids buying
stocking up with plenty of food to eat i
mean because of
well maybe not food from china but but
you know what i'm saying like
there's a lot going on there though man
their standard of living has reason look
i mean and if china's up to uh actual
crime if they're stealing intellectual
property or if they're
um ripping off americans obviously the
or should be obvious the job of the
american government
is to say no way like we're protecting
the rights of our citizens that is the
job of the government but the job of the
government is not
to bring jobs home that is not the
government and they that the job of a
proper government and they can't do it
anyway even if they try
they just cause damage so how when when
trump promises all of these things
maybe he can deliver some of it but it's
going to have worse ramifications in the
long term
but we don't think about the long term
do we we only think we're pragmatists
right we only think about the short term
so the choice today is between
pragmatists who they only think about
the very short term and go with their
feeling
versus you know post-modern egalitarians
who they're
looking at the quote big picture but
their big picture is f'd
in the a if you catch what i'm uh
alluding to here broken and awful so
these are my options today i will offer
you that individualism is the answer so
it
and don't think of it so abstractly just
ask as an individual you know you're
you're a you're a you're a successful
guy if i've ever seen one look at this
empire
good god i could get lost in this house
yeah that's true i could get lost on
your website i start going down the
rabbit hole of videos
with you know tons of views i can get
lost look in your comments section i can
get lost
that's how big uh what you've done thank
you through all this hard work oh i mean
i mean no but what's your point you
don't need me to tell you but um
individualism this is this is what i'm
talking about i'm talking about an
indiv you as an individual looking at
the world and asking what do i want and
how do i get it so that's exactly what
you've been doing
i often disagree let's say with your
beliefs but the
the methods you've employed to um you
know from what i know and
to uh to pursue what you wanted and to
build i mean isn't that
doesn't that speak to the uh to the uh
to what it is that capitalism gives us
that liberty
to uh uh property rights obviously none
of us would have any of this technology
if
intellectual property in silicon valley
and elsewhere wasn't protected
finance industry all the money that was
loaned to people who wanted to develop
these technologies
i mean capitalism other than being um
uh uh practical it actually is the one
moral system it's the one system that
allows you
as an individual to look at the world
and say what do i what do i want to earn
for myself and then you get to keep it
what do you do about monopolies there's
no such thing only only monopolies are
government
granted monopolies so there's like your
producer by the way she nods more than
you she
i would i'm just yeah yeah i'm just
listening
why do you think i'm so cocky i'm
getting so much i don't know let's let's
listen yeah yeah listen to tim
so parlor parlor decided we're going to
make our own app
we're going to have you know certain
rules it won't be it won't be absolutely
free but it'll be much more free than
other platforms
and then they get booted off the play
store they get booted off the app store
on itunes
they get villainized demonized by this
this
i don't know what you'd want to call it
you had this i don't want to say a
concerted effort but in some aspects it
was
various elements within silicon valley
many of these people know each other and
they work for the same companies and
they rotate around
destroyed their competition we saw this
with with carl benjamin on patreon
he got banned from patreon because some
activists went and found a year old
livestream on an obscure channel
where he made a bad racial reference it
was offensive but hold on okay
he goes to join subscribe star which was
a competitor to patriot to to patreon
what happens
paypal and stripe ban subscribe star
so what do you do when you do start a
new company
and then your infrastructure gets ripped
out from under you because people with
power
bully those smaller companies if we rely
on these companies so much
then i think we're in no position to be
making demands of them we need to have a
free market we have a largely regulated
market where
luckily the some elements of the economy
are fairly unregulated and we've seen
such
magnificent success stories like patreon
like
paypal which by the way anything
financial is the most highly regulated
part of the country so
it kills me that we have the financial
industry as the most regulated so that
means that if
a bank decides to cut you off they don't
want to deal with you there's very few
competitors obviously in a free market
it would not be like that so
i mean again anytime you name a problem
i'll say either the problem is
probably being exaggerated or more
likely it's a it's a result of
government regulation so we need to
solve this the pro the solution is not
more government when when does that ever
solve the problems of the uh regulatory
state i suppose the issue is that
you know we'll never meet the end there
will always be some problem and the
issue is
we're trying to reduce the amount of
problems all the time
and sometimes our solutions create more
problems than we intended
are we trying to solve all these
problems you're focused on your work i'm
focused on my work like
most people should focus on their own
lives and look at their options and try
their best to to manage i mean
well so we should not be trying to
engineer society we should be trying to
fight for
the rights of the individual and what
happens when
you have say a bridge and
let's say the brooklyn bridge right you
live in brooklyn
you work in manhattan what if one day
they said only one type of people are
allowed to use this bridge from now on
too bad build your own bridge do you
build your own bra like are we talking
about a completely free laissez-faire
economy
society i suppose sure well that that
makes a big difference obviously
we should not have public roads we
should have privatized roads
i like how that look uh look people give
me like oh come on
you know we're in a world where we're
talking how many tens of thousands of
people are watching this right now
in a world where we have all this
technology nobody can imagine that
road makers would be able to come up
with roads good enough
that we need the government to provide
them with us so all right question yeah
if a company builds a road and then
another company is like
hey i want to build a road and they say
you can't use our road
you can't use our road to transport the
materials for your road we did it why
don't you do it
they would fi i mean how about my
private property you can't drive on my
proper private property to get to that
side of the building to build your road
they would have to find another way to
get there there's got to be some kind of
agreement between i would find
some mutual like benefit agreement being
the key word here not force so if you
have an
irrational road owner who decides to
screw people or trying to
own the whole system in some way then
they're probably going to get destroyed
by competitors business is very
difficult so why isn't that happening
with youtube
well first of all in a sense it is
youtube they're constantly worrying
about their pr they don't want to look
like a frivolous
um reckless website which is why you're
able to
appeal um strikes which is why there are
competitors as well i mean
it's not i don't listen you know i'm not
exactly uh
me and youtube have not always seen eye
to eye famously but
it's not as bad as people make it seem
and also again we don't live in a
completely free society imagine if we
had a lot more capital pouring into
silicon valley imagine if
if society was full of people that
admired these people rather than
vilifying them
so the issue with youtube is that
they've subs
google is such a massive company they've
subsidized youtube
they lose money like crazy on youtube
but
because of the way they've created the
system no one can get a leg up
no other companies have tried and they
can't reach that point when you by the
way when you i'm not opposed to the idea
that the government is subsidizing
google if it turns out to be true but is
it true or is it just that like everyone
else they
live you know they live in the subsidy
state where they get google controls a
good portion of online advertising over
50 percent i believe that's not a favor
from government though is that no i
didn't say it was
oh i'm saying so when they have all of
this power
and they can you you google subsidizes
youtube that's what i'm saying
how much advertising was going on online
in the 1950s
zero obviously so google basically took
the internet to the next level and now
they're being called a monopoly
and so advertising from newspapers and
digital is collapsing while skyrocketing
and google is buying up and controlling
almost all of it
they then use that ability to make it so
that youtube can pay people out more
than anyone else can
making sure that all of the top creators
stay on youtube and youtube maintains
a con majority control over the digital
space which maintains their ability to
control advertising
which makes it a lot easier for people
to buy an ad campaign which can go on
youtube and
network websites if youtube lost its
view share on the internet and it split
up to other platforms
then a lot of people would they
diversify their advertising
their ad buys but now it's just like
google and facebook
that's like 95 of all advertisers which
by the way google and facebook those are
two very distinct companies absolutely
so it's not like there is a monopoly
but also um look i'm opposed to all
subsidies i'm opposed to all regulations
i want crimes punished and i want our uh
disputes arbitrated but i don't want
google being given any favors and i
don't want them punished for being too
successful so
so here here's the challenge i see with
the staunch elite
i don't think you call it yourself
libertarian anything like that no but
the the
the little l libertarianism this you
know going way down into the
staunchly freedom oriented i don't want
to say libertarian necessarily because
people assume
associated with the political party the
issue is that
authoritarians will build massive
infrastructure
they will use you know for instance
subsidizing youtube
through through google the parent
company or alphabet
gives a bunch of its money from its
other networks to youtube to
keep it afloat even though youtube
doesn't generate enough money because on
webv like
bandwidth is very expensive this
dominates the space
then they use that for cultural
enforcement certain ideas are allowed
and certain ideas are not allowed
your ideas are being purged right now as
we speak and you're okay with it
look i mean in the re in even in the re
highly regulated state that we live in
and even with all of these very big
powerful news companies look how
successful you've been
i mean we we don't live in a world where
like power lusting people are able to
just suppress everyone easily
it's just not the case especially any to
varying degrees
multivarying degrees i understand but
like the best
the best situation for you as an
individual if you want to live a good
life if you want to look at the world
and ask
what do i want and then go out and get
it you want liberty you need liberty
it's indispensable so
there's you know you could keep on
coming with all these scenarios i'm not
an economist i'd love to send you some
economists to come on the show that i
like
and uh have them address every last
point you're making i'm arguing with
hypotheticals right now
i can only say we a lot of the mess
we're in is because of subsidies because
of regulations and that's what i'm
that's what i'd like to get away from
but let me emphasize again we need to
get back to the view of human nature
the view of men as an individual look
i'm i'm uh
you know this is a great topic what are
we like three hours into the show now
one hour
that's cool why don't we jump over to
another topic would that be
all right with you i got a gift for you
you have a gift i got a gift do you
wanna you wanna jump what do you guys
should we talk about uh bill china bill
maher or teen vogue and getting
their ads cancelled it's more
interesting it's not china how about
team team vogue yeah all right let's
talk about let's talk about teen vogue
oh we all well yeah we'll talk about
teen vogue because this is uh uh
i'm optimistic the story the story makes
me a little bit optimistic right so this
is from the independent
i did uh cover this on my other channel
a couple days ago but it seems we have
some developments
teen vogue advertisers pull out over
editor's controversial past tweets
major advertiser suspends campaign on
the same day incoming editor apologizes
for perpetuating stereotypes of asian
and lgbtq people in a series of tweets
from 2011.
that's 10 years ago i mean i get it it
was offensive
10 years ago it's offensive today
but i think she was like 17 this woman
so i'll just give you the gist of it i
don't i don't need to you know
go through i know for the most part the
story this lady is alexia mccammon she
worked for
axios i believe and i think she's an
unethical reporter because she was
dating the guy from the bite
administration when she was supposed to
be covered
yeah yeah yeah that's very very
unethical well she made some offensive
tweets 10 years ago
now you had this this letter first of
all let me put it this way
she got rewarded she was violating
journalistic ethics
sleeping with the guy from the byte
administration claiming she wasn't
writing form and apparently she was
still writing for him
or at least in some way facilitating
these stories very unethical journalism
she gets rewarded how would you like to
be editor-in-chief of ultra woke teen
vogue for some reason praising karl marx
it's supposed to be a fashion magazine
but they write praise of karl marx sure
they reward her for this well then
around 20 or so employees wrote this
letter
saying she is an offensive racist bigot
and all that stuff
and this was a terrible choice and she
shouldn't be hired and i'm sitting here
thinking like dude come on
10 year old post you're not going to
hire that's insane
now it's backfiring on these employees
well it's backfiring on the company the
company is now losing a seven
figure advertiser because the employees
complained about the hire
so the employees effectively got their
own company cancelled
i think it's the fault of the people who
run the company because they hire these
rage bait writers
who purposefully inflame racial tensions
and i you know gendered tensions and all
these things
to make money they use these people to
write anger
rage bait so that they get clicks and
you can make money from it and
eventually you hire so many
which is critical mass and then they
start complaining about your own company
and you lose your seven-figure
advertiser
so this is more like the area of
cultural enforcement and the backfiring
and i'll put it this way this makes me
optimistic
because if they if they're canceling
themselves now because there's nothing
left to cancel
then what do they do it's like it's like
auroboros they eat their own tail and
then
well the the people that want to cancel
they don't care if teen vogue survives
or not they just want to see bernie
you're saying maybe teen vogue will
say fu and just keep doing things their
way and other companies as well so isn't
that nice when companies
look out for themselves rather than the
so-called public good
because right now the so-called public
good is not good yeah right
right no no but that means employees are
going to lose their jobs
yeah well you know a lot of people don't
really feel bad for them but
um maybe they can build solar panels but
listen i mean this speaks to the power
of philosophy you know all these people
out there arguing you know what what
drives people what drives people i mean
what people believe to be right is
largely what they do they think this is
the ethical thing to do
and they do it so i mean you look at
these cancel mob they were not born this
way
as lady gaga once put it she was not
born
like that yeah she was not born like
that wearing that trust me on that
it was my favorite joke from 2010. um
offensive i mean you know again these
people all went to school
or they were influenced by artists who
went to school
or they were influenced by parents who
went to school like
these people all were taught yeah
critical race theory post-modernism
we can't communicate we just can't
understand each other man
you're korean i'm black we are just
living in different realities man i mean
people unironically believe
that two individuals of different races
or genders or sexual proclivities
cannot communicate right by the way chat
room i know you hate
me but see i can i can punch left a
little bit i can throw you some red meat
guys we're on the same team i have
worked so hard to provide you with
quality entertainment
god forbid i try to help you out once in
a while with some
red pills where do you think this
cultural enforcement
ends up going like the wokeness the
cancel culture i mean uh
maybe at a sort of uh surface level
we'll see sort of a pendulum swing you
know kind of like there was
like kind of in the 90s you had a lot of
like you said george carlin like a lot
of like
offensive entertainment obviously that's
where i was influenced growing up maybe
you were a fan as well
i mean yeah definitely punk rock rap and
being being a badass was cool like that
was
or it was a thing to be not everyone
liked it but it was
it's like you don't want to be the
parents from footloose you wanted to be
the the you know
screw you i'm gonna go dance you know
you can't tell me what to do i mean
there were conservatives back then who
and they were not into that stuff and
they were liberal you know they were
leftists who said no they were pushing
for political correctness back then but
there was a
big element of the part of the culture
that was saying ah this is all crap
and i think uh we're gonna see more of
that i think you know i live in
hollywood
there are a lot of people they never
signed up for any of this
you know this whole like uh you know
call me by don't misgender me right
a lot of powerful rich people in
hollywood they never sign up for this to
have somebody half their age telling
them don't misgender me
they're they're giving away a ton of
power i mean you you could be imagine
you're a 50 year old dude an executive
in hollywood
and you're worth millions of dollars and
you got to this point where you worked
really hard you're making movies
you're doing great you got an infinity
pool and then all of a sudden some
19 year old who doesn't even have a job
is still in college
costs you 30 million dollars because
you're about to do this big movie
production
and you accidentally you know they found
a tweet from you from from from 10 years
ago
or look at that nascar driver a nascar
driver
lost a sponsor because his dad sent the
n-word in the 80s
but more importantly like that's that's
the craziness of it imagine you're this
high-powered you know man or woman
and you're like i finally did it i got
my condom i'm in hollywood
and then just some dumb kid calls you a
racist and you get fired
yeah i i i'm willing to bet a lot of
people are gonna start being like
nah you know yeah but even so like
what's the alternative you know where
are they going to turn to next
and people need a positive that they're
driven towards it's not just enough to
say the left is crazy the left is bad
anything is better than the left
anything is not better than anything
only the right there's the right answer
there's
there's accurately looking at the world
and being rational that is
what i'm about by the way can i give you
a gift depends on what the gift is
you're going to like it i'm not being
i'm not tricking you this i think you're
going to like this okay
can i give him a gift oh yeah all right
and can i ask you ed
watching at home may i give him a gift
we want to know what you think if you
say no
then screw him he's not getting nothing
i don't know if they're saying anything
yeah they're arguing oh are they
they're agreeing and disagreeing and oh
it's a birthday if anyone if one person
watching agrees with me then i've done
i've done i've done the impossible um
listen i know we've had our differences
a lot of you watching i just i hope we
can all agree at the end of the day
on what it is that this gift represents
i think you're i think you're going to
like it as well go ahead and
is it going to get me in trouble no
rucka got me a birthday present you know
it's my birthday
of course i know it was your birthday
is this just everybody knows is it just
a bunch of wrapping paper that would be
uh a lot of work be hilarious
a mildly funny joke a mildly funny joke
i mean just getting you to unwrap a
bunch of stuff and then we got like
nothing
the calendar
it's better than a calendar it's but it
is something you can enjoy
365. why didn't you get me this oh my
gosh what is it
i'm scared this is not for me this is
for somebody else
let's find out i can see what it is
you actually got me this and you brought
it
it's a picture of carl benjamin it's uh
more than that
open it's more than that yeah get the
cardboard out of there get the cardboard
out of there
or cut it off yeah get out your way get
out one of your weapons show us what it
can do i don't have any weapons i don't
know how many knives up here yeah
can't open a piece of tape with a gun oh
this is going to be there's a beautiful
moment
i've never been i've never been so here
i wonder if sargon if carl's watching
and he's going to be like
what is this okay this is
an amazing moment oh no i don't want to
ruin it it's got tape on it
i think it's like three in the morning
there so i don't think he's watching
oh oh he's watching here let's see it
oh what is
it's carl benjamin and there's something
else in here or what there's something
else in there
yeah yeah just rip it open oh snap is
this going to get me in trouble
i mean not with me that i can tell you
all right i am i am opening why why why
why
carl benjamin i don't know who this carl
benjamin is sargon
now now be careful with the opening
crevice
is this oh is this a vinyl is this
uh uh uh what is this
oh sweet a vinyl record of the uh
i don't know i can't play this yeah this
is really cool
is this uh what is what is this vinyl
record is this the one
one song on the back from uh this that
you're sargeras it's got the sargon song
that you could never get enough of
that's right uh it's got no i was with
you guys in the uk when you were right
almost the top viewed sargon related
video on youtube there's like one more
that's beating us it's like the ones
of sargon roasting some innocent
beautiful feminists in mind that's right
what's on this side there's two
different songs um we got some live
versions me and sargon singing it
together in england we got the one
me sargon and an orchestra we got some
got sargon sargon live featuring sargon
and sargon with an orchestra that's
beautiful beautiful
gift so for those for those that may not
be familiar carl benjamin hosts the
lotus eaters podcast we've
referenced him every so often here and
he's one of like the uh
like og gamergate people i guess yeah is
that fair to say yeah
i guess i don't really know what
gamergate is really but either but he
was he was an
anti-identitarian like you know anti-sjw
back in the day now he hosts
a much more professional i'm not trying
to be i'm trying to be very respectful
in fact
um complimentary his new show the lotus
eaters podcast actually is doing like
really really well in the uk i suppose
and uh this is because rucka wrote a
song about
the origins of carl benjamin aka sargon
of akkad
so uh thank you for this gift it's your
vinyl i've been you know i
put it on the wall yeah yeah it's a
beautiful thing you know even if you
don't have a vinyl player you can listen
to it i
gotta get one now adam's got one oh he
does
we'll have to we should also by the way
uh i've been kind of mean to you
and i want to make it up to you it was
nice there's a gift oh thank you oh wow
he's getting everybody gifts well not
everyone where's my
birthday ian's opening a gift now so we
went from this very intense political
discussion about
at the end of the day all we have is is
the music we're having a party
yeah yeah is that a cd is it this is a
scene it's going to be a sargon cd isn't
it
it better be i'll be disappointed of
sargon
i love it sargon live look at us
promoting
tomorrow well it's really promoting me
more than him these are my
cds and vinyls that i'm selling now oh
right on so you're saying you already
have them and you're pretending like it
was a birthday present i mean they're i
don't know because you found out at the
last minute it was my birthday so you
pretended i
bought these for you sure you did yeah
earlier today because he was here he's
like free for me i'm gonna i'm gonna go
for a walk real quick i'll be right back
and i was like oh i got you a present by
the way yeah i went to the local record
shop and bought this for you yeah yeah
no these are yeah these are no i got
them from ruckusworld.com they're
they're oh my catalog very cool thank
you so much i hope
i want to get carl to come out and come
on the show but cover the restrictions
and all that
show him your sargon vinyl i'm sure
he'll be happy with this now he has no
choice but to come on
and then he'll autograph it and you know
put it on the wall and it'll be
i should autograph it yeah not even not
even him
we don't we don't care about him just
just you rocco what does he even have to
do with it
look how beautiful is this yeah i'm very
happy with it we're very happy with it
we're very happy with it i like that
yeah
yeah weren't we talking about what were
you talking about we're talking about
teen vogue
teen vogue firing somebody oh yeah um
but i
i don't know how are we done with that i
think yeah because all of a sudden you
know ruckus like i got you a present and
i was like i'd like to know what that
present is
exactly well we had that story uh other
than that there's like
i think we got through bill maher yeah
and china stuff
i don't know if you if you care a lot
that that's all the stuff well i feel
like we just got
done arguing about china but let's let's
hear what bill maher has no i'm not
i'm not super interested actually okay
well a little bit about the bill maher
stuff look
yeah yeah bill maher said that the u.s
lost to china
too focused on woke competition and
lizard people
i'm i've talked quite a bit about the
bill maher stuff basically he's saying
you know dr seuss had this book removed
because of this depiction of a chinese
man with eating with chopsticks and he
says you know who doesn't care about
this
china all 1.4 billion could give
a crouching tiger flying f about dr
seuss's book
they're building infrastructure they're
building coal power plants
they're growing rapidly so i always i
always have this question for a lot of
the more uh um
liberty or i don't the right word is but
uh
capitalistic individuals and less
government how do you provide for the
common defense and i'm not i'm not
saying you don't i'm asking you quite
literally like
i mean i don't i think you're right i
don't the the common man doesn't need
defense the common man needs liberty and
bill maher he was a leftist then he was
a leftist when everyone disagreed with
him and he's a leftist when some people
now agree with him he does not believe
in capitalism he's always mocked the
idea of capitalism working
back when people on the right pretended
to be for capitalism bill maher was
public enemy number one because he said
things that you know a child thinks
about capitalism and here he is saying
the same thing he's always said
that capitalism screws the little guy
and
you know the difference is now
republicans and people on the right are
crazy
about it people hate me everyone doesn't
want to hear about it
but you know the truth is the truth well
so look china's growing rapidly yeah
they've got oil exploration in africa
and south america
yeah they they're are you familiar with
the concept of thucydides trap
no i was like beating a dead horse for
me to say because i say it all the time
on the show but
it's a general idea that when a rising
power is about to displace an economic
superpower
war breaks out so what in your view
would this world
or this country be like if we did not
have the common defense
would it just be like individuals who
are armed guarding their private
property and saying
no so i do believe in police and uh
military i'm not saying
we should abolish though i'm not an
anarchist that's that's the thing
anarchists
they're like uh a dr seuss um
bastardization of iran's philosophy
objectivism which i am i'm an
objectivist
anarchist uh they don't really have an
answer right now that i
there's one group of people i haven't
pissed off yet now i've got them all on
my back
all right now that everybody's angry now
that everybody hates me in the in the
event that uh
you know war breaks out what do we do
like it
what do you mean war breaks out war
breaks out they fire at us they're dead
they they'll know that when i'm in
charge believe me it'll be very clear
but do you do you think that there's
like a very strong free market
and then taxation would fund military
for common defense
well much more the amount of prosperity
we would see in a free market would be
just so
um just so high the average person would
have
change in his couch there's a dated
reference for you changing the sketch
something zoomers have never seen in
their life
change that they find in the couch yeah
open days huh i mean
and prosperous okay look how
we have a volunteer military right now
right like
the uh who the hell wants to go to the
military right we're busy right but
still
in a in a free country where you they
people have that option you see enough
people
are passionate about defending america
that they're willing to uh sign up for
the military right
and they get paid for it in a free
society i think you would see a lot
of people uh voluntarily funding the
military
i mean it's it would be bizarre to think
that you know let's say donald trump see
let me say something nice about trump
old donald trump you know apprentice
donald trump doing all these charity
events donald trump
we're gonna have a concert lil john and
sugar ray that's mark mcgrath sugar ray
we're gonna have
i never tried doing a trump impression
before by the way so i i know
it's coming off a little bit cringy as
the kids would put it
but i mean he would have a concert you
know where uh mark mcgrath plays
every morning there's a hello oh there
he goes your monetization
girlfriend's point no that's fine bad
yeah that sounds nothing like him
yeah uh you know and people would buy
tickets and
a lot of the proceeds would go to
funding the military that's an example
of a fun way to raise money for the
military
but other than that it would just be
wealthy successful people that love
america that want to defend it for
selfish reasons
would uh fund the military so but half
as many of that i think most people
would not do it
i think maybe conservatives who are like
you know i think you're wrong but even
even if ten percent there's a ten even
in today's world in a in today's largely
regulated
world america which is a fraction of the
level of prosperity it could be
you you would have even if today's top
ten percent who i keep hearing about
today's ten percent have all the money
one percent have all the money
that one percent could fund the military
right so like but would they
they could and if the alternative is
having a weak country that gets invaded
by all types of crazy asians then
obviously they would do it
but i mean again remember we live in the
age of pragmatism where most people are
not thinking
that long term to them everything's
short term and how do i feel right now
so we need people that treat their life
the way they treat their business
they're looking at the
the next 10 years they're looking at the
next 50 years and just
you know that proverb a society grows
great when old men
plant trees whose shade they know they
will never sit beneath that's beautiful
and uh what does that mean let's talk
about this i like this why
why do old men plant a tree they will
never get to sit beneath so that the
children who come after them will have
shade to sit under
yes and also why do they care about
children in the
after they're dead i don't know why
because while they're alive they
love life they love being alive they
love
many people that they know they love
seeing children learn to walk and sit
under trees
they love life they love their animals
they love their plants
you know they're passionate about life
and and
all these things and then to them the
idea of just planting a tree means that
at that moment their life had value like
they were they were pursuing their own
value they love
they love what that planting represents
and uh they get to lay in their death
bed
and maybe even be reminded of that
little tree and die with a smile on
their face so it's their personal values
it's not altruism it's not
oh i i'm just gonna sacrifice this time
and this seed and plant it even though
i'll get nothing out of it that's just
such an ugly
uh thing to strive for it's it's selfish
but in a rational way in a beautiful way
i'm not i'm not one who would favor a
command economy quite the opposite
but i also think not literally the
opposite end of the spectrum which would
be
an unplanned competitive market where
you don't know if you're gonna have the
budget you need to defend yourself from
an attack from an adversary like china
i think there's got to be some planning
and if there's some planning we have to
have some budgeting
so that means taxes again i believe in
having a military the government's
it should be the government doing it not
bill gates not steve jobs maybe some of
the technology those guys come up with
should be
uh licensed whatever by the government
i'm not there i'm not a legal
philosopher believe it or not
believe it or not i am a i'm a dropout
but i'm saying
but i'm saying the government should
have a military and that they should
be able to figure out what is the budget
and then is the society willing
to pay for that budget and then if the
answer is no which i don't think it
would be but if the answer is no then
that country has a problem on its hand
and
that's true doesn't mean it doesn't
deserve it by the way you would
you would fund the military i would not
well not today's military with all their
bs but in a rational society if you knew
the military's job was explicit and
clear and limited
and i was in charge of it you trust you
know i'm a good general right you know
i'm
i care you know you've seen me talk
about the rights of the individual and
the american philosophy of its founding
and all these things and you know that
the president agrees with that too
and and i'm his general and we're going
out to deal with chinese
forces that are violating the rights of
americans you would have some money to
volunteer i think you've made a
really good point if people were not
willing to fund the military
then we do have a problem and the only
reason we're able to engage in a lot of
trash wars
that seem to fail in the middle east is
because people are forced to fund the
military
and so i wonder if that regardless of
whether you're forced to pay for it or
you wouldn't choose to pay for it shows
a larger problem breaking
a larger break in this country in
general
not only that people are forced to to
pay taxes but also
again people they don't hold dear the
rights of the individual they don't see
their own life
as their standard of value they don't
see their own life as something to
to die protecting how do you feel about
conscription against it
but the founding fathers were for it
they were wrong yeah how about that
yeah about that bro good point so uh how
do you feel about second amendment
i think i'm for it but it's not this is
gonna okay now if anyone doesn't hate me
yet
i'm gonna piss them off and say in my
opinion in not everyone agrees with me
in my opinion the right to bear arms is
not as fundamental as the right to
property and the right
to speech what i mean is your property
as a billionaire
you're right as a billionaire to own
your big
uh crappy silicon valley company
is more synchro synced to me than the
the right to own a gun
i know it i i hate to pick which one is
more important but
i'm the opposite right property without
the right to property the right without
the right to
to own what you how do you protect your
own what you how do you protect what
you've produced
if you can't have the question first is
do you have an inalienable right to that
property
yes if you say yes and from my cold dead
hands take this property
then we can talk about okay well is in
is individual civilians owning guns
a a meaningful effective way to protect
property rights and maybe the answer is
yes
in which case i'm for but it's
derivative the first comes property
rights see what i'm saying i agree i
agree because the gun is property as
well
if you have no right to property well
but it's but it is conceivable and
you're gonna hate me for this but it is
conceivable that weapons
some weapons are not a right to own
because they they they cause more
destruction
and some companies cause massive
destruction like the cuyahoga river
which was mass polluted and burst into
flames
so i think you would agree that we were
well if the rivers were privately owned
then
the owner of that river would be able to
file a lawsuit and uh retire
privately owned i could carry a weapon
on my own private property
depending again on how the legal
philosophers
determine what it is that the individual
needs in order to live
a rational life in a free society but
what what if people are speeding down my
road dangerously and they're
violating my my my rights on and try and
stop them
i think you set the speed limit but this
is very advanced legal philosophy
so so i'm look you know you're saying
that
a gun isn't the same level of there
there may be some guns you should not
have for a variety of reasons because
they can cause more damage
i think massive companies cause massive
damage listen i
those are two very different types of um
questions should an individual be able
to own it like losing a ballpal disaster
that you know kills hundreds of
thousands of people versus someone with
a gun who might kill dozens
listen the right to kill somebody is not
yours
like unless it's self-defense right but
polluting someone else's property is
always wrong no matter what there's no
such thing as polluting someone else's
river
i'm trying to find that distinction
between some guns can be very dangerous
so you can't have them versus some
companies can be
very dangerous but you can still have
them in what way are companies dangerous
so like uh if you have say a semi-auto
50 bmg anti-materiel rifle you're not
intending to use that you shouldn't be
to harm another person who is innocent
using it to protect yourself your
property
from you know helicopters and tanks that
might violate your property or
for the most part we we agree in the
united states you can defend yourself
from lethal harm
reasonable fear if like you know if
somebody is threatening you
you have a way to defend yourself and
it's typically if you think they're
going to kill you
right so it is wrong to take a gun
and use it for the purpose of
intentionally inflicting death upon
someone who is not
threatening you in any way or or you
know coming at you right
right so that would be a violation to
use that weapon that was too dangerous
in a dangerous way
okay well the intended purpose of say a
chemical processing plant is to provide
petrochemicals to individuals like
cleaning solutions and fuels
it is not the intended purpose to blow
up and poison hundreds of thousands of
people
but they but it can as a 50 bmg semiauto
can be used to kill innocent people
so which one do we regulate or do we
regulate none of them
well regulation is is different than um
it making things illegal that are too
dangerous so i don't know exactly what
should be legal when it comes to like
what's too dangerous for
for people to have obviously a private
company cannot build their own atom bomb
and then
hold it over a neighboring city and say
well it's my property
no i mean you need to look at what is
the type of society where an individual
again can look at the world
choose his rational values and pursue
them without anyone else impeding on
them
and there i don't think there's any
there's any i think you need guns
okay fine but my point is and i didn't
need to pick this battle
part in the pun because i could have
just said yeah you have the right to
bear arms and everyone in the chat room
would
would stop hating me and i'll be
laughing and we would yeah and i would
get to throw some red meat
to all of the second amendment people
but i just want to be philosophical
about this and say the right to bear
arms is derivative
first comes the right to property and
the reason you have a right to own
property is because in order to live
you need to produce and you so you have
the right to speak because
speech is a expression of thought so
i i i agree with the property part and
uh and look i
i i understand your opinions i'm not
saying they're wrong
i have opinions of opinions i just think
that it is derivative the right to own
property comes first
and i think bearing arms is more
fundamental to the individual
than the billionaire individual so let
me or the corporation so i'll clarify
if you're somebody who works you know
breaks your back every day you know
farming and raising chickens or whatever
there are bad people who will steal i
mean this is this is a this is a thing
that exists
there are also animals that don't
consider it theft
it's scavenging and opportunism the
right to bear arms can protect you from
those animals who would strip away what
you've produced but also
criminal individuals who would as well
so we can even remove the
the bad thieves from the equation and
say all right what about a fox and a
coyote come on your property
can you protect yourself and your
chickens from that coyote well you'll
need a gun or at least some kind of
weapon
and i don't think you're gonna be going
up against coyotes with the machete i
think you'd be hard-pressed to find
a free-market person who is opposed to
you know comp either bearing arms or
certainly companies protecting
themselves from wild animals i think the
the controversy comes up when it comes
to
big weapons and many many weapons so i
mean if the standard is
we need a society where the individual
is able to
um who pursue the life that he wants
without being interrupted by outside
people then
again speech and property are the
fundamentals and then
the right to protect your property and
person with a gun
it's reasonable see again i could have
let this one go easy but i wanted to
be a little you know a bit of a hard ass
just to clarify that it's i think it's
derivative and then i think just to kind
of cap off this conversation when it
comes to
corporation versus corporation or
individual just legal lawsuits civil
courts and stuff is
i think reasonable anybody would agree
with right then
if like a corporation was say polluting
a river and that
and that was affecting a farmer who was
like a small farmer he would file a
lawsuit
yeah the courts the river by the way
would not be publicly owned the
river owner would be able to sue much
quicker than
how does one person own an entire river
would it be a corporation that owns it
either that yeah usually i think look i
mean it's hard for me to tell you how it
would work but i mean
back when property was mostly um
corporations were a new thing it wasn't
the brooklyn bridge like the first
corporation
no corporations existed in the times of
the founders it was
it was an american innovation i believe
i just read about this in a journal
called the objective standard
but wasn't it like they were temporary i
don't think so i think there's a lot of
anti-corporate sentiment
in the world in the intellectual world
what's what i was kidding i said it's
all propaganda
it is i think it is i mean there's both
anarchists liberal a lot of libertarians
obviously leftists and a lot of these
populist nationalists they all see
corporations as some bastardization of
the idea of property rights and all that
but really it is taking property rights
and
and kind of making them better uh
protected
in a in a marketplace so i'm
pro-corporation obviously
you're a corporate entity yourself i'm a
corporate entity we are surrounded by
the fruits
of corporate efforts honestly this is
going to piss off
the last person watching this that does
not hate me i
liked because i think i know what he
meant i liked when
mitt romney in 2012 said corporations
are people because i think i
i think i know what he meant to say is
that we're talking about corporations as
though they're
floating some floating aliens that have
nothing to do with the american
no corporations are people my friend the
the creators the workers the owners and
the shareholders and the customers are
all people
do you think that's what he meant like
corporations are comprised of people
that's
what i think he meant he did not mean to
say that literally these corporations
have a name and zip code and social
security i think they are legally aren't
they legally persons they're
they're legal persons for the sake of
like lawsuits and things like that
you know yeah that was that one but
right right it used to be i think it's
it's a matter i think the whole thing
was a semantic argument to be fair but
let's uh let's read some super chats my
friends if you haven't already make sure
you smash
the like button because it really does
help and go to timecast.com become a
member for exclusive members only
segments we do little bonus segments
after the show and sometimes full
episodes
but this is actually a fairly
interesting i mean is it i think there
was a there's a good discussion wreck up
because uh
you know we've not had uh that kind of
discussion or debate before
on this show we've had leftists on the
show who have given us very obvious
leftist opinions and we've argued quite
a bit
and uh this was interesting because it's
kind of the other direction you know
what's interesting to me is i started
talking about
any of this stuff i was you know i was
just an average dude uh
neck beard sitting in my bedroom uh like
you know the story of sargon as
illustrated in this beautiful
uh number uh-huh he uh
he was minding his own business when he
saw something happening he wanted to
speak out about so as much as i hate
what he believes today kind of where he
ended up i have to tell you it's an
inspiring story of a
totally worthless stoner lowlife
saying no i want i have something to say
you read atlas shrugged and
like changed your life oh yeah the
fountainhead really changed my life when
i first read that and then atlas
shrugged it's like
that on steroids it's amazing um so i
started talking about objectivism in
iron rand around 2016
or 2017 because um i saw a lot of people
leaving the left we're leaving the left
the left is gone bananas
well we the left what happened to the
left right
and i said guys i get what you're i get
what you're upset about
and i think you're right but where is
this going what's your positive that
you're moving towards
and if if you're just moving recklessly
away from the left
it's not going to go anywhere positive
and what we've seen is a lot of people
basic kind of shrug pardon the pun and
turn back to the left
a lot of those guys a lot of them have
turned to this sort of stringent
nationalism
that again has nothing to do with
principles nothing to do with
individual rights being inalienable and
a lot of people
call themselves centrist they're sort of
still trying to figure it out and
they're not gonna
you know they have nothing positive that
they're really fighting for and it's
it's it's not gonna
it's not gonna tame the forces of
madness on the left and right so
my friends you know think about what
what you truly believe
and uh you know and be like this guy he
was just an average duda look at that
mask
he put on that mask he became the
warlord he became
that's sargon that's what i am now and
that's what you can be too uh let's read
some of these super chats again
smash the like button because it's very
important and share the podcast if you
like it if you're listening on itunes
and spotify leave us a good review if
you like the show
let's see we got cryptic says timmy
should look into having chris duane aka
the youtube channel the greatest truth
never told on your channel
let's see john mccloud oh he says no
luke no peace luke is uh i don't know
what he's doing he went to an
archipelago
jean oh he's back john mcleod says tim
and lydia your mask maker here
how are all your masks holding do you
need to remake them or send a new
elastic
ian what is your favorite color so i can
make you one you can
blue i like green blue yeah mine's doing
all right
oh yeah um but we don't really need them
that much anymore
yeah i barely wear mine yeah out in the
middle of nowhere it's kind of like
no one's really it's not really that i i
have to say this is my favorite mask
that i've ever had it was custom made
for us and it fits me just perfectly i
put a picture of it on my instagram a
while ago and it's still it's holding up
really well
i appreciate it thank you all right
let's see matt mccormick says imagine my
surprise to see raka on the show
westby and pine grove forever i know
matt what up what up cheeks
cheeks no he doesn't like being called
that but i think in this context he'll
appreciate the shout out
all right whatever and everything says
tim been watching for years
i've learned a lot from your channel i
made a hip hop song called two plus two
equals five check it out i'm an 80s baby
with a 90s flow salute
will do zabruzi willis says love you
guys especially you tim
chan tim chan one day i'm it's son yeah
i'm a man
all rights uh adam austin says happy
belated birthday tim my birthday was
yesterday the 14th which is the most
important birthday because it is also
karl marx
karl marx's death date is that real it's
also pi day
jessie says get that star wars girl on
your show she wants to come on
uh we'll look into it peter a says tim
thoughts about starting a record label i
make death metal and would like to put a
record out on a label not run by woke
people
most indie metal punk labels are woke or
toe the line publicly
uh i don't know about starting a a
record label that's probably outside of
my wheelhouse
i just made one song so far we might
make more so we'll see
timothy peterson says absolutely
devastated today i'm a caucasian
cat that's been married and cat's been
married to a black woman for 14 years
found out from a blue check that i'm
racist because of that
that's right there was a guy who's like
he's going viral because he made some
ridiculous claim
about interracial couples being a sign
that the guy is racist and it's like the
weirdest argument ever i genuinely think
these people are white supremacists i
think they're just lying
and using the left to try and manipulate
into gaining power cultural doctrine can
i jump in here and say that song of
yours i really like that like the video
you showed me
the people the will of the people thank
you sir i respect it production wise you
really
brought that vision to life well nisha
is the one who did all the production
and then
i studios and sweden are the ones who do
the delegation takes you know
skill as well so even if you didn't
personally do it it got done on your
watch
there you go hey i supervised therefore
i i get all the credit for it i'm saying
it unironically you're putting yourself
down because if you give yourself full
credit
for what for what took place that means
those
well i didn't write credit what i wrote
i wrote all of it
yeah it's your song i don't care who you
hired i mean i it's great i'm happy for
them as well
good job but you know all right nate
hammer says two guys were arrested for
assaulting officer siknik and two other
officers at the capitol on one six
they sprayed them with something
stronger than pepper spray they are not
charged with murder-related sickness
death i saw that's interesting
dw's had sold some crypto for this rook
i still watch your e.t parody about obl
icon of youtube's golden age can i get a
raka raka
raka okay guys i know you wouldn't go
with me on the uh
whoa but can we get an ali when i go
rucka rocka ali
raka oh oh
even tim no that one i'm the one here
with the golden
guard
uh malcolm mckee says please ask rucker
to plug the ominous parallels by leonard
paikoff
he'll know what i'm talking i like this
guy yeah what's that about so the
ominous parallels is a book
that i actually gave sargon back in the
summer of 2017 when i met him and i
hustled to uh
me and my boy kirk hustled to get that
book to him
and he ended up reading it and he he
read an excerpt of it on
his channel and he got attacked by a
bunch of people who really
really uh don't like the jewish people
they're saying how can you trust this
book it was written by a jew
but you know sargon was really moved by
the book it was the
the the memorable line of the book is
ideas are the motor of history so this
book was explaining
what took place in germany it was uh it
was not because of the german race it
was not because of the economic crisis
that crisis was worldwide it was ideas
it was the german philosophers they
took they made germany a place where mad
men like hitler
could rule the people and it was
it was the idea you know philosophers
ruling the world in essence
it was mussolini too that guy was a
psychic i mean why did the italians go
along with it they were also influenced
by philosophy
they did not have the type of
individualism that i'm advocating for
all right let's see immediate casualty
care says for the
for the upcoming riots consider buying
body armor before it's illegal
chr 4568 responsible body armor
possession act
but even more importantly get trauma
supplies for training we offer concealed
kits on our site
interesting the god pill says just did
an 11 hour live today teaching options
game gme and amc and how to make life
changing money
i don't know what game stops at today
but i know it's been uh doing well for a
lot of people
austin hartley says hey tim and crew saw
some stuff this weekend about the epa
coming after motorsports
might be worth making a video about it
or having a car enthusiast on a talk
about interesting really interesting
alyosha says know the dark ages is a
myth see
history for atheist.com what is that is
that really
a theory that the church made up the
years between 600 a.d
and and 1100 or something and made up
this guy charlemagne to kind of empower
the idea of the church and since they
had all the
all the data they just rewrote it and
said this is what it was it's
500 years have passed they didn't say
that they just mean more like 100
or a thousand years of very little
philosophical innovation and it was the
rediscovery of aristotle
not aristotle's logic now aristotle
there were two elements to aristotle in
my understanding
oh you look so excited to be talking
about this you just looked at me like
why the
f are you going here no listen aristotle
is the father of science
so look at look around we better think
we better thank the chap
there are two elements to what he he
offers um
logic right facts and logic but logic
facts induction induction looking and
then observing
observing and acting on that or getting
principles from what you observe
not just dealing with ideas that tax
detached from reality
so in the dark ages you still had
aristotle's logic you had
intellectuals uh having logical
arguments and all types of um
you know rationalistic discussions about
what is god and what does god want and
all of that
but it was the rediscovery of
aristotle's induction i think by thomas
aquinas
and i think it was the arabs it was the
arabs
gotta love the arabs he they studied
aristotle while those honkeys while
those crackers
were giving aristotle no time of day so
all right when you when you go to your
uh gas station you think
you thank that gentleman i will do that
yeah all right we got one they're making
fun of you you ready
oh here we go loktar says tim appreciate
you bringing on a peewee herman
impersonator
nice to have a comedic breakup and watch
you school a low information voter
between serious topics love the show
imagine seeing a guy that had coveted 19
barely a month ago and speaking this way
to him do you know
i had coveted 19. did you wash your
hands
[Laughter]
maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think you know you guys who are
watching you got to be you got to be
nice man you know we have people on the
show who don't always agree with
everything and don't want that
you know we have disagreements i think
the intern the conversations have to
happen
and it is tough because we have a lot of
guests on the show that afterwards are
like wow that was that was kind of
brutal like your audience was really you
know being mean and i'm like
well look you know sometimes if you want
to if you want to be in this kind of
business people i people are mean to me
all the time i mean
what's uh frustrating to me is not that
all these people hate me but it's like
what if nobody
is kind of hearing my message but i know
that's not true and i know at least
one person is going to contact me or at
least in their mind
think that what i said helped them
rethink about things a certain way so if
just one person's
life can be affected positively then uh
why is it not worth my time to
come on here and uh you know give my
opinion
yeah perspective and i think it's like
if you don't listen to opinions you
don't agree with or you think are wrong
like how will you sharpen your mind
and and confront these ideas when you
preach it when you encounter them in the
real
world yeah tammy davis says dude wants
to fight a conservative invite stephen
crowder or the hodge twins
that he will calm his ass down he has no
clue what a trump supporter believes
i mean again people think i'm
criticizing all trump supporters i'm
saying here's what
in my opinion trump symbolizes he is the
pragmatist president he is the
american president that wants nothing to
do with philosophy nothing to do with
principles
a lot of his policies are probably
excellent but
policy does not matter as a certain
formerly gay
uh british chap used to say policy does
not matter
and i think although i disagree with
everything that that gentleman used to
say he was right on that point
in a sense policy of course matters has
had immediate consequences
but what matters is how you arrived at
those policies and pragmatism my friends
is what got us into this mess so let's
go back to the intellectual era
before pragmatism back to a time when
they knew damn well that the dark ages
had
had existed and they really didn't want
to go back rob lowe robslowes
says i respect this man for coming on
the show but everything he is
complaining about
he is doing it himself trump lost it's
over you are complaining about how loud
he
is but all you have done is yell and
interrupt tim oh so trump lost now
excuse me i was not whoa whoa i'm joking
he's gonna
stereotype all the time i'm just being
kind of like
i do stereotypes all right that's kind
of my thing look i took this one
individual person and i turned him into
a stereotype of himself
oh man like what i do look you you
criticized trump
and this like a lot of people then were
like i'm i'm going to put in my super
chats and i'm going to you know
you furry insanity i gotta i gotta i
gotta call you out for this one oh no he
says omg this guy is a dem
crony let's all thank china for our
prosperity okay joe jr
as much as like i disagree with you on
the china stuff they don't think you're
like
you're like the opposite of a democrat
yeah they didn't hear anything i said
i mean there are some democratic points
that i agree with i agree with them i
i think on abortion maybe not for the
same reasons as their maybe pro-abortion
i agree with them on uh
let's say at a time when gay marriage
was illegal i agreed with them that it
should be legalized but
but i mean this person did not listen to
anything i said i wanted to talk about
philosophy i wanted to
ask what is the nature of man what is
what is it that made america great what
is it that made america worth fighting
over
that that's what i wanted to ask and
also all these people hating on me
tell that to the all the people who who
bought the sargon vinyl
uh that are you know in the time we've
been doing the show tell that to them
obviously they agree with every last
word that i said
all right a magic monkey says i live in
rural new mexico
we always supported trump just because
of the wall if you don't think guns are
necessary wait till the cartels and
caravans come across your doorstep
i mean if you think the wall is that
important then we i'm not gonna reach
you here today maybe maybe someday i
think uh
a confident prosperous strong society
does not need to build walls like a
confident strong
prosperous society knows that like
people want to move here but they can't
wait to uh
to prosper they're they're too busy too
busy winning to worry about uh people
i'll tell you this people moving in and
and competing for jobs
you know where i think we agree people
got to be like pioneers again you know
what i mean
we've talked about this on the show
before think about being in london and
then being like i'm gonna get on a boat
for three months
i might die and then i'm gonna land on a
shore where there's literally nothing
and that's my plan for life and they did
that they landed on the shores
new england whatever and they're like
all right we got water and we got trees
we got to find food we got to find
shelter we got to build it they had
literally nothing
where are the people in america that are
willing to do that willing to buy a plot
of land in the middle of nowhere and
literally start building their own
ended up building their own factory
martian exploration
it's all going to be on mars yeah yeah
that that i get but like at a certain
point
there's like you know you mentioned this
earlier about people should do their own
thing and i'm like i agree
if maybe you're not having work start
making things
you know i i don't know and advocate for
liberating the economy
privatize things do you know that in
financial institutions the big ones
there is there are regulators with
offices in the banks
like this is it the government and the
banks are basically the same
person we need to separate the two i
mean
the uh finance finance and fossil fuels
by the way
are the lifeblood of all human life and
the reason we hate them so much is
because we hate look
thinking is such a big picture we hate
uh acknowledging the fact that to live
as a human being is to think long term
is to
be independent and and to observe
reality there there's a lot of people in
the super chats that are not too happy
but i thought this was actually a pretty
substantive conversation i mean yeah
we can't just have shows where we're
like i agree i agree that you agree i
also agree with you and like i agree we
have a lot of guests on the show where
it's like basically we just agree on
everything and everyone in the super
chat's like i also agree and it's like
i mean we don't who wants that and you
know if we had a good conversation and
they we got some super chats for you
then uh that's all i care about
well i mean i think if people disagree
with what you say then like one person
said
you know never have this guy in the show
again and i'm like no that's more reason
actually having that's all reason not
only again but weekly i'm actually
actually moving in this is not me this
is this is not what i'm interested in
i'm not interested in sitting down with
someone and hearing my opinions back at
me
the debate between individualism and
collectivism is so key
you need both you have to like you can't
if it's raw individualism you get
slavery
and so you need a collective to oversee
i mean if you give
a company no rules they'll hire people
for 30 cents
and and monopolize the world with
weapons so you need a government to
protect us from that that's why we built
the government so you want to go
now okay but if once you get overly
collective then the government becomes
its own monopoly
it's a maze man no raw individualism is
not slavery you cannot have slavery
where in a society where the
the rights of the individual are
protected so that's who's protecting it
well philosophically you identify that
to live is to live free to live it's
very
man you're talking about like writing up
a concept like everyone's going to agree
with each other we'll respect all these
events oh it's a government's going to
protect it
that's why we wrote the constitution the
government restricted by the
constitution
the government is the collective but the
constitution restricts what the
government can do doesn't grant the
government power to do anything
well i'm sorry to clarify the bill of
rights the constitution literally
outlines what the government does
sure and the bill of rights restricts
with the government i mean we have to
protect ourselves from mercenary warfare
you know that's the end that's the
that's the individual military source we
got it it's not the right questions of
course you need both
i think there's a balance no it's not a
balance we need to identify the right
principles and then be extreme about
them i'm an extremist
i'm a radical so what do you do when a
hundred people who are communists show
up with guns
i mow them what do you mean they show up
with guns you you have a military and a
police for that
so look the issue is you have to
organize a military and a police right
yes i mean there they have they have
uniforms like they are
a legitimate part of a free society the
government the
the courts the military and the
executive and the uh
so there's a certain degree you agree
that people will be forced to do things
no they will be prevented from violating
anyone else's rights no about how do you
pay for the for the police to it we
talked about taxation come on you really
want to have that same
literal same argument discussion i i
just think
you you have this idea that everyone's
going to agree and be happy and it's
very utopian listen
i if if i if i could get you to consider
one thing it's that
uh the work that intellectuals do in
their ivory towers is where most people
get their
their philosophy from so the fact that
most peop that
that critical race theory is rampant
right now comes from the universities
obviously we know that
uh the fact that the alternative to
critical race theory being posed is
pragmatism
again comes from the universities so the
universities is where individualism
i would like objectivism the philosophy
of iran to be offered to be
to to spread and you will see rational
people that understand
we're not all subjectively you know gra
grappling with with aimlessness with
aimless goals we are living in reality
and reality is is our frame of reference
why have you and i not come come other
than me
you know uh crapping on you verbally why
have we not
started to uh why haven't i not taken
away your stuff and started to punch you
and
violate you sexually because we're
rational beings
well we were trained not to i mean we're
violent
wild animals that's it that's all there
is to you don't think in concepts you
don't where are you from
where are you from what do you mean like
where'd you grow up uh i was born in
israel
oh there we go the last of the people
watching this that were not where'd you
grow up
so i was born in israel i lived in
detroit uh through my teen years and
through my 20s mostly and now i'm in l.a
right on and you you don't think there
are people who just don't care about
your rights and just what takes
most people not only don't care but are
are happy to violate them
but because i mean this is what we're
arguing about in a sense even some of
the good guys like you
are not willing to go all the way with
rights because at the end of the day it
is a question of what is human nature
and if we don't
agree that human nature is to in order
to survive must
look at reality and live by the data and
think
independently and think long term make
plans none of this is trained and
conditioned you need to independently
uh solve the problems you guys were
dragging the tv over because though
i ruined the camera earlier with my zoom
call i mean you got to look at reality
and you've got to make plans and you've
got to act on it nobody's conditioned
to live according to the facts of
reality all right well that's right
philosophical principles but you're not
nobody can
i mean you brainwashing exists but we're
most of us are not brainwashed
the way i see it the duff and dale show
says thanks for all that you do tim and
crew
with the uncertain future and political
duopoly it's best to be better prepared
so that we can all lead more safe
confident and self-reliant lives
prepare for the worst work for the best
subscribe to the duff and dale show hey
thanks stefan
there's a lot we didn't get to today
yeah like uh remember we were talking
about i don't know if we were talking
about this but like
i was going to tell you like it seems
like you think that when someone made
money
that they're suspect you know who thinks
that
like you think that kind of what do you
mean you're not like suspicious
or like you thought that like some
people who went from like left to right
did it because they were afraid of
consequences oh that's that that's about
like
social enforcement yeah like there you
don't think like people can just
like like evolve or change
philosophically and like change what
they believe well so i mean
look at how much money you're getting in
super chats does that mean i should be
suspicious of you because you can only
be motivated by money
no because the people who super chatted
smack talking you i just told them i
thought they were wrong and one person
said he actually gave me money to say
i shouldn't have you on the show again
and i actually said the opposite no
that's more reason to actually have you
back but maybe it's all part
how about when someone writes a letter
disavowing one of their friends because
they were accused of being a racist i
mean like that's a pretty bold thing to
do
what about someone just all of a sudden
like disappearing for a while and then
coming back totally
flipped saying i'm no longer that
politics you know i'm different now
if you agree with me that at least one
person at least tim poole
is making decisions based not on raw
vulgar material concerns but is but
based on principles
then i'm happy because that means you
admit that principles are what drive
there are some people that had like very
strange moments where like a wave of
censorship occurred
and then all of a sudden someone was
like oh i just i just realized i'm
actually
not a conservative and it's like oh wow
that's a weird that's weird timing
and i think it's interesting too like
the grift
doesn't flow it doesn't make sense that
the grift flows to the right because the
right is the dangerous position
and the right has a lower market cap
it's harder to monetize
the left is where the corporations are
where the big money is where the grammys
are
and where you're safe from censorship i
don't think anyone is really grifting
well some people are great some people
are great but
i think most people are are making these
types of decisions based on
their judgment and i often disagree with
their judgment but
you know in some cases they're making
money in other cases they're losing
money as a result of this decision
there are some channels that have like
done extremely well and
i'm not i'm not looking to name them for
specific reasons but like
you can compare their stuff after
certain key moments in the culture war
and it's fairly obvious what they're
doing like
again i'm not only talking about
leftists i'm not only talking about
conservatives
i'm not only talking about libertarians
or only anti-sjw people are formerly
anti-sjw people i'm talking about
literally everybody
and i'm going to avoid saying their
names but it includes the left it
includes the right
it includes people who have made very
obvious strategic moves
around things that have happened there
are people who have said that they're in
favor of free speech and then you see
them come out and say
i'm outraged these people should be
banned and they try and morally justify
it saying well you got to fight cancel
culture with canceled culture and i'm
like why banning anybody is wrong even
if it means
i'm in a weakened position i'm still not
going to say people should be suspended
or banned or censored you know what i
mean
anyway let's read some more super tall
birds as i've been watching tim since
sargon gave him a shout out back in
2017.
you two have always been my favorite
creators bitcoin gamestop and loom
have made me financially independent so
i'm signing up for tim cast and the
lotus eaters
i love ruckus collab with chris raygun
oh that was a
pancho nazi yeah that was great i was i
liked that
i liked what i did on that very short
feature that i had on that
swinging fists sand clubs people are
going oh that's who that was
that's right that's right i gave you
that little snippet of that song and i
could take it away
i think a lot of people that were active
several years ago
not so much abandoned their principles
but abandoned the fight itself
like it's a very stressful industry to
be in you're getting attacked left and
right
they're sending you pictures of family
members they're threatening you and then
eventually people are like dude i don't
need this i want to talk about video
games man
and then all of a sudden they go from a
political show to a i just want to talk
about video games i don't want to do
this anymore
and there there are some people who like
reach stuck their neck out and then
quickly recoiled when they realized just
how dangerous it was to do that
but if people aren't willing to step up
and stand on the front lines during a
fight then you don't win that fight
i agree that people do that but i also
think
a lot of people sort of changed maybe
their sort of
affiliation let's say they used to be on
the left and then they
they thought well maybe the right has
what i'm looking for and then they said
okay no actually i'm not i'm not at all
on board with this and they became sort
of
backed to be left-leaning and maybe this
time around they're not so concerned
about social justice warriors
they think that's an over-hyped uh
problem let's say or maybe this time
around they support
blm in a way that they didn't a few
years ago but i do see this as a
evolution or the in some cases the
opposite of evolution
a a regression a regressive leftist
direction uh as a result of their
philosophical
conviction of like where their judgment
led them so as much as i
uh often disagree with people i i do see
it ultimately as that
you know that uh i don't i think most
people i agree with you but
i'm i'm specific certain people you
think just uh like they still
sort of believe what they believe but
they they don't have the courage that
they used to have that's the way you see
it no i think they're probably always
just in it as a personality to make
money
so there are certain people who who
spoke up as like i saw something and i
believe in this and i'm gonna speak up
against it
then there were some people who just
maybe talked about video games and
movies
politics got real heavy so all of a
sudden they were like yo this is dumb i
don't
like what are you talking about this
politics and then later was like dude i
don't care to be involved in this
anymore
yeah whatever the movies are fine do you
understand that like from a lot of
people's perspective
you and sargon and many others you
started off as like reluctantly
okay with trump because you really hate
hillary but like flash forward a few
years and it just seems like trump is
like
did maybe trump do something different
did maybe something change in the in the
past few years that i've specifically
talked about
does do maybe people like you instead of
watching the content
or trying to understand what's going on
yeah just say how come two years ago he
said trump is bad and now he's saying
trump is good no
could it be i don't know maybe trump
fired 50 59 tomahawk missiles into syria
and i said wow this guy's a [ __ ] he
hired john bolton this is the stupidest
thing i've ever seen
and then in the last few months of his
of his administration he had the abraham
accords bringing about four historic
peace agreements notably with israel and
i was like wow that's really good
and then he was instructing the the
pentagon to remove our troops from the
from
afghanistan and they obstructed him and
then one federal uh official
lied to the american people about the
amount of people in syria to stop trump
from pulling them out
could it be that i said we have joe
biden who was the vp overseeing iraq a
war monger monster
who exploited his position in government
to make millions of dollars and trump
the boisterous lewd and lascivious
let's just call him chaotic individual
who i've been very critical for a lot of
reasons
he's increased drone strikes that was
bad he obfuscated the drone reporting
he tomahawk missiles in in syria
missile strikes in iran potential
escalation there but then all of a
sudden i'm looking at school choice
i'm looking at the banning of critical
race theory things at the federal
government level
i'm looking at what are the other things
abraham accords most notably and a
booming economy in 2019 and i said for
the
for what i believe is right the biggest
issues that i think affect me one
war trying to get out of afghanistan is
worthy of my
my uh my uh compliments the abraham
accords are historic
the actions he took with north korea
while not particularly effective in the
long run were still an amazing
you know that donald trump crossed the
demilitarized zone into north korea with
no security
that was bold and powerful especially
for me and what i know about my family i
saw that i was like dude could have just
been killed on the spot
but he was he he didn't worry about it
and that's the kind of effort you have
to make even with bad people
that even obama tried making and i will
give him credit for that and right now
i've praised joe biden from moving up
the vaccine timeline
you see the people who actually watch
the show probably realize there's a
nuanced opinion in these things and
they're probably some really good
reasons to support donald trump over joe
biden but what ends up happening is
the people i'm critical of who don't pay
attention and only hold opinions for the
sake of making money the real grifters
all of a sudden find themselves on the
side of the woke cult-like leftists
they opposed for years right around the
time that youtube changed its algorithm
and started banning these people all of
a sudden they disappeared and come back
with an awakening
now i'm different now i realized what
was actually right the whole time
or if they didn't go that overt or like
writing a letter disavowing their own
friends
because they were scared about being
called racists they decided that
well i'm gonna simmer things down reduce
the amount of content i'm doing and
probably just
stop talking about it you want to engage
in a fight because you claim to believe
in things but then abandon at the moment
things get hot
you are a grifter you never actually
believed in these things that's what i'm
critical of
so perhaps whatever sargon's opinions
are he actually had an evolution on
certain issues
maybe he realized you know i was wrong
about that two years ago for me i don't
think i was wrong two years ago when i
said trump was wrong to fire tomok
missiles in syria and i don't think i'm
wrong now to say joe biden was wrong to
do the same thing
both did not have congressional approval
for that but guess what the mainstream
media
prays both when they do it granted joe
biden got a little bit of flack for this
from some personalities because it seems
like the establishment is weakening as
the dsa types and more progressive start
moving in
but donald trump all of a sudden was
being called presidential because he was
blowing up
he was bombing an air base with missiles
there are many people
who don't seem to have any reasonable uh
uh
reason for transitioning their opinions
from where they used to stand to where
they are now
and my opinion seemed to be relatively
static save the second amendment when
the riots happened when covet happened
and when someone tried breaking my house
i went and bought guns learned about
them and now my opinions very much
change in the second amendment other
than that
it's almost entirely the same as it was
years ago even when i made a video while
i still worked for disney
criticizing black segregated college
ceremonies
or or black segregated protest rooms
during black lives matter when i worked
for vice
all of those opinions are exactly the
same as they've been and perhaps i
probably should evolve a bit more on
some of those positions but i haven't
instead we get a bunch of people who are
scared
they're scared the machine is winning
they're scared the establishment is
gaining ground the grammys is promoting
black lives matter
and asking for accomplices so instead of
standing tall and say
i will not move you move they say oh
i'm i that was a mistake i'm not doing
that anymore i'm not going to talk about
politics you guys see that new movie
that just came out
those are called cowards i think we got
some super chats
yep and if you haven't already make sure
you smash that like button
and uh we'll just read a couple more
because i just did a big long rant
of how long that was luminescent says a
country's policy
should be flexible not rigid open border
is a pipe dream there are countries that
don't like america
that would camouflage and to that regard
too
i seem to recall praising bernie sanders
when he said
open borders as a koch brothers proposal
and when he was actually in favor of
building a border barrier
yeah back in i think was at 2007 2008
when schumer and pelosi and all these
democrats were like we need to build a
border barrier
and hillary clinton said the same thing
uh elizabeth sink says yes tim yes
patrick massis says good guest don't
agree all the time but discussion builds
mental muscle that's exactly right
that's why i'm glad rucka came on the
show and
we had these conversations because i
don't want to just sit around with
people who are saying i agree
we're right and also i was gonna just be
like uh try to crack jokes the whole
time and just have a wonderful time
seriously three minutes in we're arguing
about the the nature of man and freedom
that's the point
yeah that's what that's what because we
we did we did discuss this a long time
ago we were
where were i think we're at the casino
at that event and we were talking about
objectivism and
stuff like that that's why i figured
you'd be cool to have on and yeah and
there's a lot more to discuss
and charles in ohio just bought a sargon
cd so i just want to thank him for his
uh
that fight with ted cruz comments got a
lot of people like i'm your huckleberry
you were like i'd like to get ted cruz
in here to agree to a consensual
physical fight or whatever
yeah so what did huckleberry do no no so
you know the saying i'm your huckleberry
no
it means like i'm your guy like i'll
fight you oh no no no
just ted cruz people are like i'd like
to see him come down here i'll i'll take
it i'll offer him money
all right let's just uh let's just we'll
do a couple more
uh race schwarzbach says get him ian
it's like it's individualism versus
collectivism no i agree it's
individualism versus collectivism but
why would you give
this much to collectivism because i
think government is collectivism i don't
think it is i think a proper government
protects the individual
but who runs it individuals that are
appointed for that particular job and
improving themselves
well they get the job but when you say
individuals you mean it's a collective
of individuals
conceptually it's a collective but there
is no collective that is separate from
the sum of its individuals i do agree
with that
the individual part of the collective
oversight of the individuals
i'll read i'll read a couple more and
then we'll continue decentralizing the
i'd like blockchain a lot for that
purpose let's
we'll talk about that how about we talk
about technology and individualism for
the extended members only thing but
we'll read a couple more super chats
jb says it's time for the civil war to
officially oh no we can't say that
uh nope i'm not going to read the rest
of that super chat sorry jb very
insanity says look this guy isn't as bad
as destiny by any means i just don't get
why
why it seems he thinks it's okay for us
to depend on china from earlier in the
talk
i don't know if you got the essence of
the point i was making
but thank you for the first part of that
which was almost a compliment
case closed 93 says rucka you you forget
you did a trump impression in
my name's obama in 2012. ironically i
just never found myself doing this whole
today pow was transferred over like i
never really tried to do that type of
trump my
at my you know 25 million view
i was born in my own hospital now like
some a few people are like oh that's
that guy that's right
that's right all right guy you've been
hating this whole show
hashtag real name says i think rucka is
wrong on a bunch of stuff but over the
years he has definitely helped me work
through my ideas
he caused some great conversations well
that's uh
wonderful but next can you just like
kind of agree with me so i know this
show was not a total waste of time
there's a lot of people that want to
fight let's fight wow so many ted cruz
fans i never would have guessed this
uh 37 says you have unlocked jre tim
poole for tim cast mode is that what
that was
that was what yeah i might as well be oh
dude ah
can you do that whole screaming uh that
whole rant again just just do it again i
want i have a better better
all right i don't remember what i said
maybe if they actually would watch the
show they would say
can you just oh i had one guy like i've
known for years he's like
i used to be so proud of what you were
doing and then i realized you were just
pushing an agenda and i was like what
agenda is that
and he was like it's very clear that
you're trying to you know just
your pro republicans and these and i was
like when have i praised the republican
party
certainly i said there's good things
about them for sure so i'll take that
you know absolutely
the critical race theory stuff pushing
back on that but i'm pretty sure i think
i've
always said i don't like mitch mcconnell
he doesn't do anything the republicans
obstruct
and they're part of the uniparty but
what would how do you respond to people
that are saying you're
you're sort of grifting in the sense
that you're like you're getting so much
money in prominence and you're
you're sort of rising up to be a force
to be reckoned with on the right like
doesn't that make you
on the right doesn't or does that make
you kind of suspect
well i think if you go to the actual
forums where
you know the hardcore conservatives are
they actually don't like me all that
much
and i think it's funny like when i went
on stephen crowder it was really was
really funny the last time i went on he
was like you know him
you love him or you hate him and i'm
like you see there you go and so
uh like look my american values test i
just took it i get moderate libertarian
that's that's that's that's what i get
and uh my political compass is center
left and i think the issue
is this audience that listens i think
the one thing that actually just defines
them
is discernment of media right
a critical eye towards media is probably
the principal factor
so if someone comes in and or if like a
news outlet says
donald trump did a backflip the people
who watch the show are the kind of
people who looked for the video to see
if he actually did a backflip
and they'll watch my content and they'll
criticize me when i got things wrong and
send me corrections whereas people who
watch
mainstream corporate press are the
people who just believe whatever it is
they hear
so what ends up happening very critical
of democrats because they're the ones on
the offense and republicans don't do
anything
so if the democrats are saying something
like we're going to push hr1 and rapidly
transform
voting in this country and then i
actually did a whole segment where i was
like i actually agree with a lot of this
bill
well the reason it's the focus on the
democrats and the republicans because
republic republicans literally did
nothing
they did nothing nothing happened or a
good example is when
the republicans pass these tax cuts
donald trump gets these tax cuts passed
and then the progressives start saying
is the tax cuts for the rich which they
still do
and then matthew iglesias from vox.com
comes out and says
it's it's like what did he call it he
called it success that progressives has
to
have convinced americans they didn't get
a tax cut when actually
trump did give a middle-class tax cut
there's a lot
shall i continue i mean i'm not getting
the anger that i was getting him
before that rant and like when i saw
that comment i realized oh i had the
perfect comeback but like i don't want
to
say it because what if you have another
angry an angry rant in you
probably all right words all jumbled up
let's keep let's keep going well let's
we're going to take it to the we've gone
a bit over on this one we're gonna take
it to uh
timcast.com and we'll make it this
exclusive you can swear in that one and
give me something angry please or what
pisses him off guys how do i get him
to me interrupting him a lot no when i
get a bad mana curve in hearthstone
meaning well you've got to fix your data
no no no no i'll be playing tavern brawl
right
and right now they're doing one where
it's like the deck is
uh the current tavern brawl is you
choose a class you get some base cards
and you get hallucinations which
generate you know three random cards
from your opponent's class
and then what happens when i'm playing
and every single time i use a
hallucination it's a six or seven mana
cost card
and i can't even play anything and then
they're just dropping one two three
drops and they're just hitting me ping
ping ping and then i can't even actually
play
when you build your deck are you
building this tavern brawl meaning you
get a you get a pre-built deck but
random
there's a rng in it so the current brawl
is giving you random cards
and i'm like what's the point of playing
the game and you know what i get it it's
rng you play the game that's what you
get so i'll just concede like okay fine
i get it
game over video games frustrate me there
goes matter
unfair randomness why do they frustrate
you so
i i like games where you can
understand the system figure it out and
then
increase your ability like get better at
the game and then do better
when there are certain games that are
just like designed to frustrate you
by you know like a good example of this
problem was why the us did not release
super mario brothers 2 in the us they
created something called what was it
called like doki doki island
the original set mario 2 for nes
had a bunch of tricks in it that were
meant to punish the player for no reason
for instance in the original mario
brothers
if you get a mushroom you grow and it
makes you strong in the
in the second one that was in japan you
would hit up hit a box or whatever and a
like a brownish green mushroom would
come out of purple and it would kill you
if you got it
and the american companies nintendo of
america said
but we just trained everybody how to
play this game now you're punishing them
needlessly so they're frustrated before
they even play
the original mario the first world shows
you how the game works jump on the
on the bad guy hit the brick get the
mushroom get the star it's all there
get the fire flower the green mushroom
gives you a life the second version was
just ridiculously hard
and constantly trying to trick you like
oh you know that thing you normally get
oh that one killed you hahaha
yeah so video games can freshen when
they do that thank you for the feedback
oh imagine if i said that after that
big rant i didn't give i'd have given
you a high five
that would have been that would have
been epic that has been like perfect
either tonight or my life is a failure
at least i thought about it after we got
some monday monday night quarterbacking
or monday morning quarterback
all right let's uh let's okay we're
gonna read one more i mean we've gone
definitely over and we got to do the
members only stuff but uh daniel
bundrick says do you think the reason
politicians don't solve problems is
because problems are the reason they get
elevated to power to begin with
i call it the save the save the whales
effect do we
even need al gore if we had nuclear
i certainly think uh non-profits because
i used to work for them are supposed to
fail
the uh not fail i'm sorry uh um go out
of business
yeah so i used to work these non-profits
and when you work for a small one they
say the goal of this nonprofit is to go
out of business
we should not be needed however what
happens
they grow they get donations and they
find a new mission the mission changes
like you know greenpeace i worked for
them their mission originally was to
obstruct nuclear testing
that's a that's a that's a pretty great
uh mission in my opinion
because nuclear testing was was very
destructive in a lot of ways blanketed
the earth with reductive materials and
really affected a lot of how we do
science uh was it like reactive decay
testing and things like that
now it's like one of the reasons i quit
was it just kind of felt like
whatever sounded good they'd find a new
new thing to fight against
so i know that being said i agree i
think politicians certainly love
problems but i also think we never meet
the end
so there's always something to complain
about there's always something that
someone on youtube will be upset about
there's always some video to make
it's one of the reasons i've started
reducing the content on my other
channels
because i actually am self-reflective
and thought to myself if i'm doing six
segments a day because
honestly there's 50 things i could be
watching and as i often say complaining
about on the internet
that's probably not a good thing and i
should shift the focus in another
direction which is why
i'm putting more effort in this tim
casserole podcast timecast.com and it's
why
honestly this channel is doing better
and growing because it's where my energy
is at
i want to make sure we're having more
substantive conversations expressing
different ideas arguing with people on
certain things and not just being uh
here's the latest thing i'm mad about
today
so like like this episode was very much
us having a discussion on
government politics economics philosophy
and less so
us just screaming about you know what
thing we particularly hate the most
although we are critical of a lot of
things so anyway that being said black
people in your case
china oh i'm i'm i'm convinced
i'm afraid when i watch the way the
nazis blitzkrieg into france
i think that maybe china could do that
to the united states and that russia
wouldn't
do anything about it and if russia
didn't do anything about it and india
didn't that would be
probably china but not
electricity inaudib and they won't it
won't if it all happened i'm talking
they didn't expect them to go into
france i hear you i hear that i mean if
they want a piece of tim pool
you know he'll be well buckled you're
terrified we're gonna go to the
members only my friend you gotta smash
the like button i i can't
you know it's it's it's it breaks my
heart every day you know we
i gotta remember to say smash the like
button when we first start because we
really need those uh those likes man
it's it's
this is the only reason i do this i
don't care about the money i just look
at the podcast every day and i'm looking
at the likes
and if we get the likes then i i i get a
dopamine release you know
it's i'm kidding you know there are a
lot of people like that though um you
don't get a dopamine kick from like
a bunch of likes not anymore not anymore
when i first started i was really
excited like seeing the views and
everything
yeah but this is another thing about
like i don't do weekends anymore and i
got rid of three segments per day
because it was it's bad it's bad it's an
addiction
like social media is devastating to
people and people need to go outside
more
and like we got chickens you know what i
mean yeah it's simple things man
this is not all that there is but i do
want to make sure i'm doing right by the
people who watch and
and and like this content and you know
uh uh
really do think it's valuable so we're
actually expanding
more importantly i think it can't just
rely on me
so when i was doing six segments six
individual segments
every single day no days off and then
monday to friday this show
i was like yeah i'll probably die and
then what's left of the company and the
people who work here
so we need to launch new shows new
brands and that's what we're going to be
doing soon so that being said my friends
thank you so much for hanging out and
thank you for smashing the like button
can i shout out some stuff
like uh yes yeah oh sorry to interrupt
yes
that's all i do around we'll do we'll
we'll so uh go to tmps.com for the
exclusive
segment we're gonna do next and uh we're
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you're listening on the podcast leave us
a good review because that also really
helps
all of this engagement and interaction
you're basically telling
you know these companies whether it's
itunes or whatever like hey this is good
stuff we really like this and it helps
you can follow me all social media
platforms at tim cast my other channels
are youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comtimcastnews and raka's
got some stuff to mention uh you know i
mean i
almost wasn't even gonna do this i i've
been focusing more on like comedy music
and stuff what i know that i've
excelled at with pissing off plenty of
people but not
necessarily you at home so i think you
might enjoy it check out rucka rucka
ollie go to ruckusworld.com by the way
the sargon vinyl for a limited time can
be yours
and if you want it signed you know get
in touch with me maybe we can work
something out
uh and uh you know because i've had some
great discussions with tim in the past
i've i decided i'll come on here and
have this conversation so if you invite
me somewhere and if i say no it's
nothing personal i'm just
i got my priorities focused right now
but i do do a podcast by the way
a few mornings a week or five days a
week we got a revolving
host uh host cast it's me a hedge fund
manager
a famous actor and nico sotira capolus
and the podcast is called the daily
objective
so so subscribe to us at the iron rand
center uk
that's awesome man thanks um thanks for
coming i i want to hammer home too how
important it is i think it is to talk
about things you don't agree with and to
have uh
tolerance is is very important we got to
be strong mentally
in the next 20 years probably more than
in the last 200.
well we have we have to be important if
not more we have to be a serious people
yeah we really got to start accepting
each other whether
for our differences as well as our
strengths similar but but i do think
like
you know if you if you may disagree with
like raqqa imagine all of these leftists
who refuse to watch this show just
because they disagree with me
yeah right be a beacon of what you want
other people to be
yeah be resilient and listen to the
ideas you disagree with so you know
what those ideas are you understand them
and by listening to this show
maybe maybe some people agree with you
and they've heard your argument with me
and they're like that's a good point for
morocco or maybe vice versa
now the next time you hear that you're
gonna be like actually i heard this good
point from this dude
and it makes you stronger and smarter i
love the way you defend yourself
uh that type of conviction and certainty
needs to be
recognized and applauded and that needs
to be uh philosophically identified and
uh you know we need to use that type of
approach looking at the facts and using
logic by the way you can hate the
chinese but you gotta love their food
and thank you for this hospitality it's
only the ccp i'm a little
nervous about the people are amazing
well it's the communist mono party if
they
provide the type of food and hospitality
you guys have given me while i've been
here and then call me comrade
hey guys follow me at encrossline.net
also if you want to
thanks yeah i uh i was really glad to
have uh
ellie tonight and i think that uh having
these kinds of conversations is really
important this is way more important
than sitting down and just blandly
agreeing with someone
i'm sarah patchelids on twitter and
mines and i'm real style patch lids on
instagram and gab
you know whenever we have guests that
people disagree with they love to super
chat the most to express themselves and
i gotta say i really
respect that and we don't do it
intentionally
but what we do intentionally is try and
bring on ideas that will be challenging
but i absolutely am grateful to all the
people who super chatted because they
wanted to express themselves challenging
certain ideas and thank y'all so much
for hanging out
we will have an exclusive members only
segment coming up at timcast.com
for those that are interested and we'll
see you all there bye guys
you